to
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who moves
the house adjourned from the session of
march 31st 2022. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed a
you guys have it the house is adjourned
house will attend to a prayer by house
chaplain reverend bob stewart pastor of
saint paul's united methodist church in
manchester
good morning
oh gracious and loving god we are
grateful for today as we assemble to do
the necessary work for this great state
of new hampshire
we ask that you would be in our midst
today to guide and direct us in making
decisions
that out only reflects what is in the
best interest of those we represent
but that our decisions are acceptable to
you for it is in you that we put our
trust
we know that you are a god of love and
yet we see and experience hatred in so
many ways
we see the mass shootings happening
across our country
we see the hatred and injustices across
our country and our state because others
do not agree with our own point of view
we see the hate that exists throughout
our world
we pray o god that you would be with the
people of ukraine and the people of
russia that fall victim
because of the decisions made by their
leaders
mighty one we pray for peace and pray
that peace will begin with each of us
first
may we be able to say to each other
i don't agree with you
but i still love and care about you
lead us o god in that decision today and
in the days ahead
a loving and merciful god we come
together today to mourn the passing of
one of our own members of this new
hampshire house of representatives
we pray for representative catherine
rogers who was laid to rest last friday
catherine is now resting in your loving
arms
we pray for her family and friends
and for all of her constituents that she
represented in conquered area for the
last eight terms
catherine was a sheep of your own fold
a lamb of your own flock
a child of your own redeeming
receive catherine into the arms of your
mercy
into the blessed rest of everlasting
peace
and into the glorious company of all the
saints that have gone before
i also ask that you be with all the
leadership of this house
keep your guiding hands upon them as
they lead this body to the best of their
abilities
to you oh god we give you our praise and
glory
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
merrimack representative maureen mooney
chair recognizes the piccolo opera youth
chorus of manchester will now sing our
oh
[Music]
me
it's
[Music]
foreign
uh
house will attend to requests for leaves
mr speaker the day illness
representatives alisaya burch ellis gorg
mary griffin hopper lawton nelson
nutting wong o'hern pantalakis schultz
sophocetus wazir wilhelm the day
important business representatives ayer
cody de palma gold hayward pamela
manjapudi macbeth mckinney murphy
pimentel rice sanborn samuro
the day illness in the family
representatives eliot porter
the day death in the family
representative leishman
disease of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome lou gerish
guest of representative tallersky
darlene gildersleeve guest of
representative cordelli madison kelsey
and leah izzo daughter and guest of
representative kelsey
alicia collin and margaret ceneaux guest
uh daughter and grandchild of
representative abbott
lily walsh guest of representative
terosian
jacqueline hagopian kevork bardakian and
julia jonesian guest of representative
genesion rita matson guest of
representatives notter mooney and hobson
john and kelly houstead and laurie hill
guests and wife of representative hill
scott couture dong may she jennifer
paracedo and bernard and diane nagle
guests of representative mooney there
with us in the gallery today
the house will now attend to a memorial
resolution
mr speaker
house resolution 22
whereas we have learned with profound
sorrow of the passing of our colleague
and friend katherine rogers who is
serving her eighth term as a state
representative from her native city of
concord
and whereas catherine rogers was a
dedicated public servant who beyond her
time in this house served as a concord
city councilor merrimack county attorney
and merrimack county commissioner
and whereas a fierce defender of our
most vulnerable citizens
including youth victims of domestic
violence and the elderly catherine
rogers used her offices for good
establishing protections for all new
hampshire citizens in a caring and
compassionate way
and whereas a lover of animals and
protectors of those with no voice
katherine rogers sponsored countless
pieces of legislation to improve the
lives of animals great and small in this
state
and when the time came to shave her head
while battling cancer she turned the
event into a fundraiser for the spca
and whereas despite her professional
background as a campaigner an unabashed
pride of being called a lefty
kathy rogers cared about this house and
the many personal relationships she
built over the years irrespective of
party touching the lives of all
assembled in this chamber now
now therefore be it resolved by the
house of representatives in regular
session convened
catherine rogers be granted the highest
praise and accolades and given our
profound thanks
for her service to new hampshire and
conquered the city she called home all
her life offered by the house of
representatives
please stand and join me in a moment of
silence
in memory
chair recognizes the member from
mr speaker
uh queen elizabeth whose birthday it is
today said in a speech in 1992
that was her honors horrible
horrible year because of the misfortunes
that beset the royal family
for those of us here in the new
hampshire house
because the number of good friends that
we've lost this session
on both sides of the aisle
this is quickly becoming our honors
horror bliss
kathy rogers was born on march 7th 1955
here in the city of concord
and grew up on the cronkite heights
where she spent the rest of her life
the heights back in the late 50s and
early 60s was a very
rural
and quiet community
where everyone knew their neighbors and
everybody looked out for each other
over the years the heights grew
immensely
and kathy's sense of community also
changed no longer was it bounded by the
wards eight and nine boundaries
herc since the community had no
boundaries
to her it didn't matter if you grew up
on allen street on the heights
or you grew up in afghanistan
you were her friend
and you and she was there for you
as the clerk has mentioned kathy had a
wonderful legacy of public service
she served here in the new hampshire
house
honking city council
she got a law degree and was a
prosecutor for the allenstown police
department
elected as our merrimack county attorney
and then merrimack county commissioner
eventually she came back to here to her
second love
her first love being her two pugs
some time ago kathy was diagnosed with a
terminal illness
which occasionally caused her great pain
her last speech was here on the house
floor on march 31st
and after that speech and the vote she
called the doctor to say the pain was
now greater than it ever been before
and a doctor told her to come up to
concord hospital immediately to be
admitted
kathy's response is i can't leave now
we've got an important vote coming up
and she waited
eventually she was admitted to the
concord hospital and she passed in there
she died
kathy had a lot of things to be proud of
in her life in her career
there's a clerk
mentioned i think one of the things that
she was most proudest of
was the number of friends that she had
in this chamber
on both sides of the aisle
both democrats and republicans
to kathy there were no walls between the
two parties
the only walls in this chamber of the
small number of people that have built
walls in their own minds
mr speaker this fall
the people of the heights will be
electing a new state representative
to sit in kathy's seat
no matter who they elect
no one can ever replace the honorable
recognizes foreign
this is from kathy's funeral
going strong and steady just like her
so i thought i'd wear it today in honor
of her
you knew as soon as you met her
that kathy was going to be one of the
most intelligent individuals you'd ever
get the honor of speaking with
kathy and i love talking about art i'm
an artist by trade and kathy a patron
with a clear eye for what brought her
joy and what made her think
kathy had a generous heart and there was
an occasion when she wanted to buy a
birthday gift for a little girl in her
family
she wanted it to be art themed and as
she often did asked for my
recommendations on art and craft gifts
she loves art and she is so talented
what should i get her
that depends i said do you like the
parents
because if not boy do i have a
recommendation for you
that was the day i taught kathy about
glitter
as anyone who has ever worked with
glitter knows it sticks around forever
just like the legacy kathy left us with
kathy and i would banter back and forth
until the wee hours of the morning it
wasn't unusual for us to be planning
mischievousness and at two o'clock in
the morning my bubby used to say
the smart ones always have trouble
sleeping
kathy reminded me a lot of my bubbie
one of a kind her own person
all day every day unforgettable
you can tell right away when you meet a
strong woman the kind of woman that
doesn't suffer fools
we would vetch to each other for hours
into the night we were both
unapologetic when we maybe should have
been more reflective and alternatively
should have been sorry yet finding
ourselves apologizing for the things
that weren't our fault
kathy had an individual superpower she
would never miss a meeting or a chance
to defend stand up for and fight for the
most vulnerable and when she stood up
she would win every single time i never
met a legislator in the state house that
didn't respect kathy rogers work her
ethic her institutional knowledge and
tenacity
kathy was a lifelong democrat with an
arm extended in cooperation and
friendship across the aisle
i am so lucky to have counted kathy as
one of my mentors she was more than just
a good teacher
we grew so close to be friends and she
was truly an amazing individual
like many of my mentors know she would
always try to give me advice but i would
never listen this would of course elicit
a solid eye roll and a sigh with well i
guess you have to learn the hard way
don't you she would tell me many times
that she was more misbehaved than i was
i understand i would do the same thing
when i was your age she said back there
there wasn't the internet you have to be
better than me be better try harder
kathy never sugarcoated anything when
you messed up she would tell you to your
face and she could be bruisingly blunt
her feedback sometimes left her
left your self-confidence shaking but
you always knew she was right
she was constantly looking out for me
and had my back even when it wasn't
popular to do so
cathy was one of those people that you
don't complain to
unless you have a real problem you never
wanted to waste her time on frivolous
things or small issues this was the kind
of woman that would save the world and
make it her responsibility to clean up
the entirety of any mess even though
that mess hadn't been created by her
kathy was a true advocate her joy came
from service in saving vulnerable people
animals and even trees
anyone who had cursory introduction to
her would know all creatures great and
small occupied a big piece of her heart
this lady was always there for the fight
even at the expense of her own life
she fought all the way until the end
if it had been up to her she would have
preferred to pass away while we were in
session or during some other important
meeting that she never missed because
kathy never missed a moment
promise me she said the other day on her
deathbed promise me you will keep
fighting
don't stop what we do is too important
and you have to promise me you will
never give up
i nodded yes i promise i won't give up
as cassie as kathy laid there in her
hospital bed making me promise that we
would all continue our service and that
we would never quit it was not lost on
me that the fight continues in many
forms of service if even if we are not
in office it does not mean that we
cannot change the world and the world
has a lot of changing to do
because we're all fighters she said i'd
like to think that we don't just give up
if you are a true friend to the
honorable katherine rogers you know
exactly what keeping a promise means
i had the honor of traveling to the end
of the road with kathy she left us
surrounded by love
and she left squeezing the very last out
of life she didn't waste any of her
moments so i'd like to leave you with
this message no matter how hard it gets
no matter how sorry you feel for
yourself
don't quit because somewhere someplace
kathy is watching you and if there's one
thing you don't want it's to be on that
woman's bad side
kathy i love you thank you for sharing
what precious time you had left with me
i miss you and reflect on the time we
had while writing at 3 a.m because my
insomnia partner is gone the
conciliatory thought for me and all of
this is that you get to meet my bubby
and in the back end of my sleepless mind
i can hear the mischievous and joyful
cackling of two tough extremely
intelligent women whose soft hearts had
rough edges planting from above cooking
up some sort of mischievous joke to plan
on us all and kathy rogers your memory
of the previous foreign be placed in the
the house will now attend to a house
resolution
mr speaker mr speaker house resolution
whereas new hampshire celebrated the
100th anniversary of holding its first
in the nation primary in 2020
and whereas new hampshire enjoys a
civically engaged citizenry who make
candidates better prepared for high
office through retail politics
and whereas new hampshire has a long and
storied tradition of conducted well
conducting well-run free and fair
elections
and whereas new hampshire has withstood
many challenges to its primary in the
last century
but through statute and the hard work of
election officials and party officers
has kept the new hampshire primary the
premier political event of the
presidential race
now be it therefore resolved that the
new hampshire house of representatives
affirms its century-old support of the
first in the nation presidential primary
and strong commitment to retaining the
tradition that has withstood the test of
time offered by the house
question is on the adoption of the house
resolution number 23 are ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
house resolution 23 is adopted
the chair recognizes the member from
[Music]
the chair recognizes the clerk of the
house for the reading of a proclamation
the state of new hampshire buys actually
his excellency christopher t sununu
governor a proclamation in the year of
our lord 2022
new hampshire tartan day
whereas the declaration of our broth
pronouncing scottish independence was
signed at our broth abbey on april 6
1320 by bernard linton
chancellor of scotland and whereas
helping to expand freedom for all people
scotland abolished slavery in 1777
by freeing african-born slave joseph
knight who had been sold in jamaica and
brought to scotland and whereas the
united states declaration of
independence was modeled in part after
after the declaration of our broth and
whereas nearly half the signers of the
declaration of independence and nine of
the country's original governors
including new hampshire's governor were
of scottish descent and whereas scots
and scottish americans have made
outstanding contributions to both the
united states and the state of new
hampshire in the fields of science math
medicine education politics business and
the arts
and whereas the united states senate has
passed a resolution designating april
6th of each year as national tartan day
and whereas saint andrews society of new
hampshire along with many other scottish
organizations including
new hampshire scott the new hampshire
school of scottish arts and thousands of
citizens claim scottish heritage in the
state now support scottish heritage day
now therefore i christopher t sununu
governor of the state of new hampshire
do hereby proclaim april 6 as new
hampshire tartan day in the state of new
hampshire and call upon the citizens of
the state to commemorate the struggles
of freedom and historical achievements
of scottish americans in new hampshire
the chair recognizes the member from
rindge representative hunt for the
purposes of the titan day ceremony
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker incredibly this is the 25th
anniversary of the new hampshire house
celebrating tartan day
when our former colleague the la late
representative steve avery from dublin
first led this ceremony in 1997
most in the chamber were not yet
representatives
some were not even alive
however this day has become not only a
symbol of honoring great people
but has become a historical part of our
house tradition
one in which many of you come to look
forward to and so
we're back
april six is tartan day adopted by the
president congress and our governor and
marks the day of the declaration of arba
which was signed in 1320
which was the declaration of scottish
independence from britain
this document is among
those credited as a model of our
declaration of independence perhaps one
of the most quoted lessons from this
document
is this quote
it is in truth
not for glory
nor riches nor honors
that we are fighting
but for freedom
for that alone which no honest man gives
up but with life
itself
the scots have pioneered the way in
civilization
alexander graham bell with the telephone
alexander fleming with penicillin
adam smith founding political economics
arthur conan doyle with his mystery
novelis
john paul jones with modern naval
tactics
john muir creating the u.s national park
system and of course there's sean
today would not be possible without
groups like our friends at the new
hampshire scott
who have organized the wildly popular
highland games every year since 1976
and our friends for the school for
the school for scarce hearts has been
teaching for 23 years
and the students here today have
achieved notable success
as solo competitors at various levels
including
piper camel webster who is now the new
piper for the dropkick murphys and piper
sebastian benedito who is heading off to
notre dame
as their type major this fall
with that mr speaker please join me with
the welcoming of allison miller marielle
webster
will todd
matthew mccloud schlattman
james fox chris baum
sebastian benonito and campbell webster
[Music]
so
so before we entertain with more music
i'd like to see all those with tartans
today to please
so uh
because
okay oh here we go
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
so
do
please remain standing
mr speaker
we now arrive at the solemn part of this
ceremony where we remember and pay
tribute to our departing house
colleagues who have passed away this
session
so as we rise
those among us have passed in our
special way representative dick kinch
david danielson
doug lay
barbara shaw
renee cushing
[Music]
do
so
thank you mr speaker and with the
representative
who will grace us with a scottish
blessing
may there always be work for your hands
to do
may your purse always hold a coin
or two
may the sun always shine upon your
window pane
may a rainbow be certain to follow each
reign
may the hand of a friend always be near
to you
and may god fill your heart
mr speaker members of the house thank
you for your attention today
as we celebrate this wonderful event
once again i'd like to thank our friends
at the school for scottish arts the new
hampshire highland games we've missed
having the celebration for the last few
years but i'm grateful for your
attention today and so until we meet on
the bonnie the bonnie banks of loch
lomond may your days be long and
let's have a cheer
hip hip hooray
[Music]
do
so
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
mr speaker from the committee on
criminal justice and public safety
senate bill 7
376 removed by representative abbas
from the committee on education senate
bill 394 removed by representative
cordelli
are there any other bills to be removed
representative osborne moves a consent
calendar with the relevant amendments
that's printed in the days house record
be adopted ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
under house rules from the committee on
criminal justice public safety senate
bill 303 fn is referred to the committee
on finance
from the committee on election law
senate bill 366 fn is referred to the
committee on finance
from the committee on environment and
agriculture senate bill 379 fn is
referred to the committee on ways and
means from the committee on executive
departments and administration senate
bill 313 is referred to the committee on
ways and means senate bills 363-fn and
443-fn are referred to the committee on
finance
from the committee on health and human
services and elderly affairs senate bill
275 is referred to the committee on
finance and from the committee on
transportation senate bill 417 fn is
the house will now attend to the regular
calendar
if you haven't already done so please
the majority of committee on children
family law to which was referred senate
bill 458 fn
enact relative to the sununu youth
center service and operation of a
replacement secure facility
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
representative cody belanger for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee on children
and family law to which was referred
senate bill
458 fn having considered the same
reinundable degree with the majority
report with the following amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with amendment senator joshua carla for
the majority amendment is 1470h
printed in house record 15 pages 51-54
chair recognizes representative lynn to
speak against
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the amendment i want to
emphasize that i support the underlying
bill but i rise in opposition to this
amendment
existing law under
the new hampshire juvenile statutes
provides that there can be no commitment
for for the crimes of theft crimes such
as false swearing or breach of the peace
types type crimes but it provides a
three strikes strike exception which
allows but does not require commitment
if a minor has three
prior
adjudications
commitment is only allowed under
existing law
as a last alternative that nothing less
no lesser type of disposition would be
appropriate
the amendment
says that a minor can never be committed
for any non-violent crime such as a
property crime no matter how serious
and how how serious that crime is and it
eliminates the three strikes provision
so that it doesn't matter how many prior
adjudications the minor has to just give
an example if you're away from the for
the weekend or if your business is
closed is closed and you're not there so
there's no danger of violence to you and
somebody breaks in commits a burglary
breaks in
cleans you out
all of your property or destroys your
house or whatever
under this amendment
that minor could not receive one day in
commitment even if the minor had
committed the same offenses three times
previously i should end so
this this amendment sends the message
that in new hampshire property rights
don't mean very much
because if it's if you just commit a
property crime there's no possibility no
matter how serious it is or how what
your prior record is that you that a
minor could ever receive any period of
commitment
so stop and think about how does that
make sense in light of the sort of smash
and grabs that have been going on around
the country
i asked one of the primary supporters of
this legislation if any other state in
the country has tried to do something
like this and he told me that as far as
he knows the only state that has even
come close is illinois which which it
provides that a minor cannot be
committed
for misdemeanors but as i say this bill
goes for this amendment goes further it
says a minor cannot be committed for a
non-violent offense even if it's a
felony so if they destroy your house
steal thousands of dollars of property
from your house if there's no violence
involved the minor cannot receive any
kind of a commitment
um
so
proponents say that this bill will
reduce the po oh i'm sorry i should may
i should mention
this bill the amendment contains a
subsection m which the proponents refer
to as the judicial bypass
that does allow commitment
for a felony for any felony but again
it contains a limitation that the that
in order for there to be a commitment
the minor has to pose a danger of
serious bodily injury so again it sends
the message that unless the minor is a
danger of a you know of some kind of
violence hurting you physically if
they're just a pr just a thief no matter
how long or how serious their record is
no possible commitment what kind of
message does that set more importantly
stop and think about this
if there's no possibility that a judge
could impose a sentence of commitment or
a property offense
even when a judge wants to impose a
lesser sentence probation
counseling treatment or whatever there
are some minors who are resistant to
that and unless the judge has the stick
of being able to say if you don't do
these things you're going to jail or
you're going to to a juvenile commitment
facility what's the incentive
of of the minor to do to to comply with
those things i submit that that for some
miners there's just no incentive at all
some you know
based at least on my experience not all
miners are you know there's so there are
some that are that can be pretty
hardened and that's unfortunate but it's
true
so i should say to you
that i
um the proponents of this bill have said
that
this will reduce the population of the
sununu center which we all favor we all
think that's a good idea but i have to
but i what i submit to you is
that that's already the case the
population has already been reduced
under existing law as i the last that i
checked the population of the sununu
center was roughly 10 to 15 people about
half are in pre-trial uh detention and
half are submitted are are serving a
committed uh disposition but the so the
center has already the population has
already been reduced
i support closing the sununu center and
building a new facility and that's why i
support the underlying bill
458 but this amendment goes too far
it's true that commitment of a minor for
a property crime should happen only
rarely i completely agree with that
but this amendment says never
it can never happen and that's the
problem
uh
so that's for those reasons i ask you to
vote
press the red button vote against this
amendment so that the underlying bill
without amendment may then be passed
thank you very much does the member
uh thank you for taking my question i
i'm i'm predisposed to voting right on
this as you've uh asked us to
but i would like to understand something
the juvenile justice system was set up
so that indiscretions
of poor judgment in your youth
can be dealt with without a permanent
scar in your record what i what i'm
wondering is if we create
such an exclusive blanket prohibition
against incarcerating
all property crimes
are we
essentially asking the courts
to try many more of these juveniles as
adults
thereby
messing up their record the rest of
their life that's what i'm worried about
is there an unintended consequence of
diverting these kids into the adult
thank you thank you for the question
representative edwards and you raise an
excellent point and i would ask though
those who may be disposed to vote for
this amendment i would ask you to think
about the unintended consequences
because
this
passing this amendment will take away
the op an important option
of a judge in a case where we're
involving a property crime where the
judge feels that this is a serious
enough situation that some commitment
towards to a secure facility is required
but but the the the minor should i and i
should when i say a judge it also would
require a prosecutor but where they they
believe that some commitment is required
but that the but that the we shouldn't
go so far as to invoke the adult
criminal system where a person if it is
if a person is petitioned as treated as
an adult and is committed and is found
guilty then the person goes to an adult
jail if you take away this option
for that that class of cases that i've
just described it seems to me you make
it more likely the unintended
consequence will be
more prosecutors will say well my only
op this person should be committed for
some period of time but i can't do it
under the juvenile statute the only
option i have is to petition the court
to have this person treated as an adult
i don't think we want that
so i i think you raise an excellent
question representative edwards does the
member yield to further questions
i do
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
taking my question under the amendment
it says under part two adds placement of
children who are quote not serious
violent offenders
unquote is there do you know of any
definition in statute or in common law
or the new hampshire supreme court has a
clear definition of serious violent
offenders
i
can't
i can't think of a case off hand but i
think that uh you know i think i don't
and i don't know that there's a
definition in statute that has that you
know serious violent offender means i i
don't think that there's such a
definition in statute i you know i think
probably the court
you know a court could construe that
pretty easily to say has to have a uh
it has to be a violent offense
and has to involve
uh you know
some level of violence
okay follow-up
does the member yield a further question
yes so potentially under the bill
depending on how the courts later
interpret it uh someone a group of 16
and 17 year olds might commit a home
burglary or even steal a car
if there was some intent later on to
commit some other violent crime if the
prosecutor doesn't have evidence of that
they wouldn't be able to detain them or
if they don't have evidence sufficient
evidence that they can introduce in
court does that mean that the uh
the courts would have just another vague
area or gray area where they wouldn't
know whether they could detain them or
not
if to he said i uh if i if i understand
your question correctly as i think that
if the
if the state of the evidence was such
that the only charge that could be
brought was for a property crime and
there was not there was no evidence that
the mine that the miner was you know
physically violent or a physical danger
the answer would be no the minor could
not be committed
either for that crime
even if the minor had you know
three or four or five or ten
uh prior
uh commitments
all right thank you i guess i wore the
does the member yield the further
questions
thank you mr speaker and thank the
member for taking my question
if i hear you correctly um would it be
correct then to assume that if a house
is vacant and a miner commits arson and
burns that house to the ground
and even if they become a serial
arsonist and burn houses that are vacant
to the ground there's no way to put them
no i believe and i and i stand to be
corrected if for people that are
proponents of this amendment i don't
think it would cover i think arson would
be it is
is uh uh an offense for which someone
could be committed because that that
would be considered to be burning down a
building would be considered i believe
to be
uh uh
well it's a i think it and it's it's a
felony that's specifically listed in the
bill
purely a purely a property cri theft
type of property crime
even if it's a felony even if the person
has you know a significant prior record
of that could not be the basis for a
commitment
thank you
i didn't realize that we were
encouraging about locking kids in prison
did you know that when an adult commits
a misdemeanor we don't just throw them
in jail they put on probation or they
let go they pay bail
i think we uh
heard many bills this session about bail
reform
this bill that we're talking about
is building a new facility
excuse me
thank you
the amendment
the amendment intends to reduce the
population of the current facility
we are spending 13 million dollars a
year
on a
144 bed facility
thank you the population
what are the unintended consequences for
kids i'll tell you i've been there
i've lived in that facility i have lived
in group homes
group homes
are community-based services
most of the kids in group homes
have had a felony
juvenile diversion programs
you have to follow a plan
that your jppo which for those in this
room don't know is a juvenile probation
parole officer
puts in place for you and you have to
follow that to a t
in these programs kids are required to
follow a plan
and the system
is set up for youth to have success
that's what we're talking about
setting kids up for success
if the intent is to just lock kids up
for any crime that they may commit
we might as well throw this whole thing
out
throw it out the window it's got a
pretty far fall
and keep that 144 bed 13 million dollars
a year facility
instead of keep teaching kids that if
you commit a crime you're going to
prison
let's teach them that their mistakes are
mistakes
and that tomorrow is a new day
because in fact they are kids
and they're short-term
they don't understand the consequences
studies have proven this
for that i ask that you support
with me the committee amendment
that we have worked incredibly hard for
so that we can move on with the rest of
a roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
question before us
is the majority
amendment
14708 printed in house record 15 pages
51-54
the house will come to water
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative lin
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this amendment
20 2022 1470 contains overbroad and
inaccurate legislative findings which
are totally unnecessary to the substance
of the legislation and if i know that
this amendment contains two sections
that is five and six
uh which propose inconsistent amendments
to the same provision of existing law
and if i know most importantly that this
amendment would prohibit committing a
minor to a secure youth detention
facility for a property crime that does
not involve violence or the threat of
violence that the minor is a danger to
public safety no matter how serious the
crime or how many times the minor has
committed similar crimes in the past and
would effectively announce to the public
that in new hampshire violation of
property rights is no big deal then
would i press the red button to defeat
this amendment so that the underlying
jail recognizes representative d simone
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
that there is some confusion
concerning whether to detain
or commit youth to a facility
if i know that in this
wonderful state
commit
adults
to a prison facility
when they commit a misdemeanor
so why are we
committing youth
when they commit a misdemeanor
that's very confusing to me
if i know
that this amendment
speaks to the necessities
to keep youth
and the inhabitants of this state safe
then would i press
the question before us is the majority
amendment 1470
[Music]
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
all members president had an opportunity
under an 82 voting a 150 voting a
majority amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative lin
thank you mr speaker
the house has rejected uh my view that
the that the prior amendment should not
be adopted i accept your judgment i i
offer amen the um the amendment now
before you floor amendment uh
as a fallback position that i submit
will make the current bill better
let me tell you what it does it
basically does four things first
it removes over broad and incomplete
legislative findings which are totally
unnecessary to the substance of the bill
second it replaces sections five and six
of amendment 1470 that's the one you
just passed
which both address the same topic of
pre-trial adjudication
pre-adjudication detention and are
inconsistent with each other it just
adopts one of them it basically says and
i completely agree with proponents of
the bill you shouldn't be able to detain
somebody
pre-adjudication if they couldn't be
committed
you know at following an adjudication
and that's what my amendment does
three most important
it changes the new proposed section m of
the of the amendment you just passed
um
which is an amendment to rsa 169 b19 one
roman numeral one
to allow a court to impose commitment to
a juvenile facility as a last resort
deposition
a disposition not only in cases where
the minor poses a risk of serious bodily
injury
but also where the minor poses a
substantial risk of significant property
damage or loss
or
where because of the seriousness of the
conduct the commitment is an appropriate
sentence under all the circumstances
lastly my amendment also slightly
changes the wording of subparagraph m
so that while the court must find the
facts supporting commitment
by clear and convincing evidence based
upon reliable uh
reliable evidence it is not required to
comply with the formal rules of evidence
remember this will be a sentencing
proceeding and i
this may be a little bit inside baseball
but in sentencing proceedings courts are
the courts are not required to comply
with the rules of evidence to make the
rules of evidence applicable in this one
case would be would make it very
difficult and very time consuming and
more add more cost
to the disposition of these cases i
respectfully urge you to press the green
button to uh adopt this amendment and mr
speaker i'd ask for a division vote
does the member yield to questions
i do
thank you thank you for
taking the question
so
is my understanding correct that under
the
language if we did not adopt this
a high schooler could spend all four
years of their high school going from
car dealership to car dealership bashing
in every single car
um
a night
and your amendment
without ever being committed
but your amendment would allow some
discretion to the judge to be able to
commit that person
thank you for the for the question
representative yes the answer is that my
amendment would allow that again it
would still have to be a last resort the
judge would have to find it by clear and
convincing evidence that this
that commitment was the only appropriate
disposition and that nothing less
restrictive was appropriate but yes it
could could impose commitment in that
circumstance
it's a member yield of further questions
i do
generally sooner you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
taking my question so this language just
doesn't overturn the last amendment that
the house proposed it just tries to
provide some clarification so that there
are certain circumstances if for example
if someone's going to has committed a
property crime and then might commit
other uh serious crimes uh that the
judge might have just some discretion to
that's correct that's correct the
amendment that you just passed has a
adds a new subsection m to the law which
creates a sort of judicial override the
problem with the one in my view and the
one with the one you just passed is it
allows the judicial override only if the
poses a threat of serious bodily injury
my amendment says
that it can be
you can have the override if the if the
if the miner poses a spread of serious
bodily injury but also if the miner
poses a risk of
substantial risk of significant property
damage or loss
or if given the seriousness of the of
the conduct the court concludes that
it's the only appropriate disposition
under all the circumstances then it
would allow the court to have the
for the record hb 254
which is what this is attempting to
amend
uh was passed by this body on january
there was an attempt
to table that bill
and it failed overwhelmingly
now before us today is an attempt to
but it was never brought before the
children and family law committee
didn't have its day
in the hearing that's why we have it
before you today
this amendment is dangerous
for years
legislatives that as legislators that
have sat in the seats before us
have worked diligently to reduce the
population of sysc that is why today you
have a population of 15 and not 144 bets
filled
the amendment
that is attached to this bill to build a
new youth center
and if this amendment passes
you might as well again throw it out the
window start over and let's fill those
bets i'm against that
let's move on
support the uh do not support this
amendment with me
and let's stop wasting taxpayer dollars
on the current facility
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is floor amendment
this will be a division vote the chair
recognizes representative lynn for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that there had that there was never
back in january or at any other time an
amendment proposed like this amendment
that is now before you
and if i know that this amendment
removes the overbroad and inaccurate
legislative findings which are now
contained in the bill as amended as you
just amended it and which are totally
unnecessary to the substance of the bill
and if i know that this olympic this
amendment eliminates one of the two
inconsistent provisions contained in the
amendment you just passed so that the
bill will simply state that a minor
cannot be detained in a secure facility
for any offence for which the sentence
of for which a sentence of commitment to
such a facility could not be imposed
and if i know
that the i the notion that
adults
are never sentenced to jail for
misdemeanors is a fantasy i sentence
awful lot of in people to jail for
misdemeanors and i know a lot of my
colleagues did the same thing that's
just a fantasy and lastly if i know most
importantly
that this amendment permits a court to
sentence a minor to a committed sentence
when the minor has been adjudicated
delinquent for either a felony offense
or for a misdemeanor offense where the
court finds that there is no less
uh
severe just uh severe disposition that
will protect the public uh and in the
case of a mis of in the case of a
misdemeanor that miner has to have three
prior adjudications then would i
then would i press the green button so
that this amendment may be adopted thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizer representative simone
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that house bill 254 passed
this house with a vote of 264 to 87.
and if i know that this amendment
removes
house bill 254 from this push from their
portion of the bill
and if i know that the current amendment
that is before you
is absolutely detrimental
to
this youth in this state and finally if
i know that you just
you just voted affirmatively
on the prior amendment and this undoes
what you already voted for then i would
question before us is the floor
amendment one six four row this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press the red button voting stations
president had an opportunity to vote
160 voting a 171 voting a
we're now back to ought to pass as
amended with the majority committee
amendment
are you ready for the question
division has been requested members will
the question before us
is the ought to pass as amended
majority committee report
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button boarding stations
mcgee
all members president an opportunity to
vote
244 voting a 88 voting a committee
financing
uh
house bill 458 is referred to the
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred senate bill 291
next establishing a committee to study
the issue of unmarried co-inhabitants
domestic partnerships in common-law
marriage considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator jennifer rhodes for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being able to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
david muse for the minority of the
committee
care recognizes
senator muse
thank you mr speaker
in this body we spent a lot of time
talking about property rights and our
discussion of the last bill actually
veered into property rights as well
but when it comes to how property is
divided between unmarried people who
live together and then split up
our laws are unclear and they have gaps
as we heard in the public hearing on
this bill this lack of clarity opens the
door to one party being able to take
advantage of the other financially when
the relationship ends
retirement assets that normally would be
split between a divorcing couple
remain in the hands of the cohabiting
partner who controls the account
domestic partner health care coverage
can simply be canceled after the split
meanwhile in new hampshire the death of
one partner after less than three years
of living together can leave the
surviving partner with nothing
unless provisions were made in the will
as for child custody laws the good news
is they apply to both married as well as
unmarried couples
but the bad news is when the split
involves unmarried people
one partner may have to take on the
burden of paying for child activities
and other expenses with no financial
help from the other
we are living in a society that's slowly
changing
according to a recent study by the
center for family and demographic
research at bowling green state
university
unmarried couples today are living
together for longer periods than in the
past
but fewer of these relationships are
leading to marriage
that means in the years to come
we're only going to be seeing more of
these issues cropping up
when unmarried people do things like buy
houses
have kids and share financial
arrangements
the member will suspend
it's awful loud in here if you're gonna
have a conversation take it out
into the anteroom the member has a right
to speak
you may continue
thank you
the purpose of this bill
is not to propose or impose some sort of
a shot in the dark solution or to impose
anybody else's solutions or sense of
morality uh on anybody
the mission of this bill is to do one
thing and that that's to do one of our
most important jobs as legislators
it's to bring in experts it's to take a
close look at our laws including a very
relevant rsa that goes back to a time
when women in new hampshire weren't even
allowed to own property
and then decide if making changes make
sense
while i know that this particular
legislature seems to have no love at all
for study committees
it has shown a definite and deep
affinity for protecting property rights
and that's really what we're talking
about here
i urge you to keep showing that affinity
and devote red on the motion before us
so another motion can be made and i ask
for a division vote thank you
thank you thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of inexpensive
legislative
senate bill 291
none of the issues presented to the
committee
addressed any areas of law that had that
weren't already well settled under new
hampshire law
the issue of common law marriage
has already been settled
the issue of the different ways people
can own property
what this would do is they want to study
those laws
which it appears that many people
already did
and come to the conclusion that they're
already
well settled
if
two people living together
it's
their choice whether they wish to get
married
if they don't want to get married or one
of the
people living together does not want to
i'm not sure why that would we need to
study on how that would impact their
property rights if people are unmarried
and choose to buy property together
whether to own an equal shares as joint
tenants or
to own an unequal share that's their
decision
these are all issues that can be
addressed already under the law
common law marriages
which have been abolished in the state
for good reason
because people who would live together
what would happen is
20 years later if one of those when
they're not living together that other
person can remarry and what would happen
is the person who lived with that person
20 years ago says oh i was married to
that person and they claim her right to
their estate
more than i can even calculate
clogging up the courts more than they're
already clogged up
so i'm not really sure what needed to be
studied that is not already well
concluded under the law
the although i sympathize with some of
the testimony presented to the committee
the issue was raised again
a consultation with
a any attorney anyone with legal
background would have been able to
advise that person of what their rights
were for that reason
i would ask that you join me push the
green button and support the committee's
recommendation of nxp to legislate thank
you mr speaker
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
bye
the motion before us
is the majority report of inexpedient to
legislate
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
i rise to oppose the itl recommendation
if i know
property rights are among the most
sacred and important rights
and if i know the existing laws that
govern the division of property in these
cases
lack clarity when unmarried
relationships end between cohabitants
and par domestic partnerships
and that this lack of clarity can result
in the loss of property should one of
the parties take advantage of the other
and if i know
passing this law would solve that
problem
through further study of how the legal
clarity that these cases require can be
incorporated into existing laws
would i now press the red button to
defeat the itl recommendation
so an ought to pass motion can be made
thank you mr speaker
chair recognize representative rhodes
mr speaker if i know that new hampshire
has mechanisms in the law to protect
persons choosing not to become married
including statutes regarding any
children born from the relationship
and if i know that a couple if a
comfortable if a couple is uncomfortable
with becoming married they have the
right to keep all of their assets
separate just as a married couple does
and mr speaker if i know that if a
couple is if that a married couple is
just as vulnerable to have their account
liquidated as a married couple and this
could all be solved with a will
would i now press the green button to
support the committee recommendation
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of an expedient to
legislate this is a division vote you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
vote 179 voting a 143 voting day the
on criminal justice of public safety to
which was referred senate bill 306 fn
relative to penalty penalties for
various motor vehicle violations
consider the same report the same with
the recommendation
to build a lot of past so john bourdinet
thank you
i don't know if they can fix that um
they spoke of
the person getting 60 days in jail
on this really really
and i mean really bad accident
you know the person should have got a
lot more
but there was other laws that could have
got him more
in the county attorney and
the person that caused this accident
it was the plea deal's fault that he
days also during testimony mr speaker
and i asked them about if your cell
phone is in the cradle
and you use it
can you be fined under this new
law
just by using hands-free
you know well i guess it's not
hands-free because you're touching it
but
whoa
that that's a red flag for me mr speaker
the state police also mr speaker said
that
there are other laws like negligent
driving distracted driving that would
get that person that caused this
terrible terrible accident
more jail time
and that's really what this bill is
after is to
make sure
that if there's a real bad accident
that you are punished but we have
and the other thing that really bothers
me mr speaker on this bill
is
i was coming up through the tolls coming
to the state house this was uh you know
several years ago
and mr speaker there was a woman putting
her makeup on
and i'm going whoa okay that's nice
and as i'm driving up the road another
time
there's a guy with a full newspaper
spread right out
and i'm thinking well that's nice
i see it constantly
and mr speaker i asked
one of the officers
because bottom line when i drive down
the road i see a lot of people on their
cell phones
you know holding them right there
and they shouldn't
i i'll be honest i don't know how they
do it because i would head right in the
ditch but people
must learn how to do it and they do it
all the time
and when i'm i'm in manchester a lot
and also in goffstown i've never seen a
goffstown police do it but i've seen
plenty of manchester police texting why
they're driving or looking at their cell
phones or their computers in the
hillsborough county sheriff's i see it
all the time
and i'm going well okay so who's going
to enforce this if they're doing it
you know mr speaker it's just you know
they should have included everything if
they were going to do this and i'd
probably still be against it
but bottom line
the new hampshire liberty alliance
and i just look at it mr speaker
they're only picking on cell phones in
the person that caused this accident
could have got a lot more jail time
they pled a deal and that's why he only
got 60
days so
hopefully you'll vote with me and mr
speaker ever since i'm way in the back i
don't know if you would hear me but i
would like a roll call on this
thank you mr speaker remember yield to
questions
yes
remember those you may empire
thank you mr speaker thank you mr
speaker and thank you for taking my
question
uh is the mic off i can't hear you
can you hear me now
uh
so my question is am i reading this
right on the gold standard that it says
that this could increase this to a class
a felony up to 15-year jail term
for using a cell phone is this correct
yes
uh follow-up
remember yield to further questions yes
isn't it so
that negligent or even reckless
vehicular homicide is only a class b
felony so if you if you're driving
recklessly and you kill someone without
a cell phone that's only a class b
felony but
just driving with a cell phone could
raise it to a class a felony if you
don't cause an accident correct and
that's why this bill is is not you know
it wasn't thawed out they were just
after that one person to punish that one
person which is already spent 60 days in
jail so there's no punishing him and i
mean i feel really bad for that lady
that spoke in front of us i mean it was
it was a horrific accident and you know
just thank god she's still alive because
that's the only reason she is
okay one for their follow-up remember
yields further question
um
was it your committee when the new
hampshire civil liberties union came in
and they they said something that was a
that was important they said uh bad
cases make for bad law in other words
taking one specific case where the law
was misapplied
uh in in one particular narrow
circumstance um that we tend to pass the
legislatures around the country tend to
pass bad laws based on a single case
where the the court system didn't
operate properly was that your committee
was that the criminal justice committee
where they've said that
yes and that's what this bill is
it's it's we're going to have a bad law
here that isn't needed
all right thank you very much thank you
thank you mr speaker
this law is not based on one case
we just heard that
the good representative sees people on
their cell phone all the time
this law does not make a felon out of
you for using a cell phone this law is
very specific
if you
drink and drive and cause an accident or
cause an accident and it is revealed in
the investigation that you did it
because you were using your cell phone
then
the enhanced penalty would apply
because one woman was brave enough to
come in and testify does not mean that
this is about one person
the woman who came in and testified has
had seven or eight surgeries her entire
life has been changed she lost her
career
and she had a son with down syndrome who
she didn't know who should be able to
take care of because somebody thought it
was more important to send a text than
pay attention to the road
again very clear this is not enhancing
the use of cell phone crimes this is
enhancing the use
of cell phone while you get in an
accident
or
your oui already serious offenses
and it's also not a mandatory it just
gives the court the option to send it to
you at a higher rate
and
frankly if you can't put your
cell phone aside and you cause someone
to almost die or die
i think we would agree that you deserve
a higher rate of sentencing
burgess requested a roll call is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the committee
report on senate bill 306 of auto pass
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you
mr speaker
if i know
that the person could have got more jail
and mr speaker if i also know
that the state police
that testified is unaware is not sure
that if you use your hands free if that
constitute a crime
and mr speaker
if i know there is plenty of other
distracted drive-in that is not included
in this
would i now press
the red button
so another motion may be made thank you
mr speaker
chair i recognize representative abbott
thank you mr speaker
if i know that senate bill 306
gives the prosecutor the discretion to
seek an enhanced penalty when there's
egregious circumstances
with a current penalty under the law
does not fit the crime
and mr speaker i know
that the scope of senate bill 306 only
would apply to mobile electronic devices
that are not if they're not permanently
affixed to the vehicle
but i go ahead and push the green button
and support the committee's
recommendation of ought to pass thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us is the auto pass
motion on senate bill 306 this is a roll
call vote you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed to
press the red button voting stations are
representative
all members president an opportunity to
vote
201 voting yay 132 voting a committee
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred senate bill 401 fn
an act making appropriations to the
department of transportation for local
highway aid
into body worn and dashboard camera fund
permitting the department of
transportation to operate dash cameras
and fleet vehicles considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass to terry roy for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report with
the following resolution resolve is
inexpedient to legislate serve john burt
from the minority of the committee
thank you
mr speaker
when this is an ominous bill which most
of us are against because they packed a
bunch of stuff in here
there is some good stuff
that i'm not opposed to but the main
thing that i'm opposed to
is our privacy
mr speaker
i talked well i
asked questions to the dot gentleman
that testified in front of
us and in the bill it says that they
have to delete
this is about dash cam so they're going
and even though
the hra is against it there's part of me
that says you know what dash cam is
probably a good idea
because there's accidents in
you know that they need
you know this this uh
tape if there was an accident
but where the problem is because the way
the d.o.t has to delete the tape in
three days
so i asked
well that three days can some another
government agency come in and grab that
tape
and he said yes
and i'm like whoa we can't do that
that's not right
and then he said
we could even take the tape and use it
for training or commercials or anything
so that's why in my blurb mr speaker and
is because
on november 6
four hundred thousand four hundred and
nine thousand three hundred and twenty
five
people in new hampshire or 81 percent
past cacr 16.
and let me tell you what it said
cacr16 a yes vote supported
this amendment to provide that
individuals have a right to live free
from government intrusion in private
or personal information
while me driving down the road getting
caught on the camera of a d.o.t truck
like i said if they deleted the tape and
nobody else could get it just like at
the uh tolls when you go through there
they delete them within you know a short
amount of time
i could support that
but when another government agency can
come in and grab that tape
and use it for whatever they want
i'm against that
because it is against the constitutional
amendment that both sides voted
also mr speaker the hra is against this
and they quoted let me quote it for you
or they i'm going to quote them
the bill is also permitting the
department of transportation to operate
constitution part one article two dash b
right of privacy so it's even in
you know the constitution which we
passed
so mr speaker i hope people will see
that and not see some of the good in
there and say you know what we have to
kill the bill because that's the only
right thing to do
because mr speaker lastly new hampshire
voters were very clear on november 6
2018 when we did pass cacr16
they do not want government
surveilling us
they do believe in privacy
and we voted for that
over 80 percent of new hampshire people
wanted this
thank you mr speaker remember yield to
questions
yes or no yes
remember yields
thank you mr speaker thank you for
taking my question i've been reading
this uh the different blurbs on this i
understand the body
worn cameras by the police department in
need because of what's been going on in
the call across the country in the last
couple of years but i'm i don't see any
reason nor do i understand what it is
why does the department of
transportation need
dash cams we've been doing quite well
without a mother i understand there's
some big reason out there that we all of
a sudden have to put dash cams on
department of transportation vehicles
you know they showed us pictures of you
know it's only once or twice a year of
accidents that when cars fly down the
highway and they smack into a d.o.t
truck luckily you know nobody's been
hurt seriously
so they just want that video of the
accident
thank you chair recognized
representative
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation about to pass for senate
bill 401
in respect to the right to privacy
which we all enjoy
has traditionally always always applied
when the person or the individual has a
expectation of privacy
i don't need to give examples of when
with the dot vehicles that we're talking
about
they are vehicles that are
driving on the highway
which is a public way
that's really open to the public
and therefore i'm not sure what if any
expectation of privacy a person would
have
for operating
a vehicle
in public
police officers have dashboard cameras
and they have no they're now starting to
use
body cameras as well
senate bill 401 will
increase the grant money that we
actually passed it was part of hb2
already
so the
local communities could actually apply
for those and receive some funding
towards facilitating that program at the
local level
it's about privacy again we're talking
about
something in public
now i understand
one of the parliamentary rules is we're
not supposed to debate witnesses who
testify for the committee so when a
witness
makes a statement that i
strongly disagree with
such as i can just get a copy of this
video for any reason i want and give it
to wherever i want it it would be
inappropriate to debate that person but
if you read the bill
and it's the
it's on the lines 23 to 24 and it's only
one page long so i know it was presented
as a long builds one page
now just read it this
the stored recording may only be used by
the requesting party for a lawful
purpose
including as evidence in a judicial or
administrative proceeding
if for some reason a government actor
for whatever reason would decide
that they wanted to get a copy of a
dashboard camera video
from the d.o.t that
for whatever reason just showed a
vehicle driving by
and they then attempted to use that to
well unless they demonstrate a lawful
purpose they have no use for it and it
was a complete waste of their time in
the government's time
so again it's only can be obtained by a
lawful purpose there's a three-day
period
in order for a right to know request
to be submitted by the public if it's
not retained if there's no retention
period the problem is it's nothing more
than a live video feed
so there has to be some type of
retention period in order to actually
make the request
with that being said i'll get to the
positive sides of this
there will be
one of the parts of this bill that it
would offer over 30 it will offer 36
million dollars to local communities
who have
for bridge and repair
projects
infrastructure projects
and it's going to be done based on the
priority of need by those municipalities
so anyone
who has in their
their town their district who has a
bridge that is the structural integrity
is in jeopardy
like my district in salem
intent to my colleagues from salem
this will provide
financial relief for that community
so please join me
push the green button let's support our
push the green button support the
committee's recommendation ought to pass
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of what a pass on
senate bill 401
are you ready for the question
roll call i was waiting for that
is that sufficiently second a roll call
has been requested it is officially
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of auto pass and senate
bill 401 the roll call vote
here i recognize representative for
thank you
mr speaker if i know
on november 6 2018 over 400
000 people
voted and passed cacr16
which would allow privacy
against the government
that in public
the public
can take pictures videos and everything
else they want in public
because the supreme court is very clear
on that with the first amendment
but if i also know mr speaker
that the government
does not join that group of the public
so they don't have a right to spy
and lastly mr speaker
if i know the new hampshire voters were
very clear on november 6 2018 with the
passage of cacr16
they do not want government intrusion in
their private or personal information as
the new rsa
236 colon 130 subparagraph g
would cause
if
senate bill 401 was passed into law
would i now mr speaker press that red
button and join me so another motion may
be made thank you mr speaker
joe i recognize representative roy for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill is about dash
cameras
and if i further know that a dash camera
will pick up your license plate and
maybe the make of car
and if i know that you have no
expectation of privacy in your dash in
your license plate or the bumper of your
car
and if i lastly know that the benefit of
this bill is 66 million dollars going to
fix roads and going to fix bridges
and the dash cam hang up is the small
part of the bill
would i then
press the green button and agree with
the bipartisan criminal justice
committee recommendation to pass this
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of auto pass on senate
bill 401
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button to be
opposed to press the red button voting
all remember as president had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
241 voting a 93 voting a committee
senate bill 401 is
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred senate bill
456 fna
an act establishing a law enforcement
conduct review committee and police
standards and training council making an
appropriation therefore
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
for what reason to the member rise
thank you mr speaker i rise to make a
motion to table senate bill 456.
the motion is in order the motion before
us is the table
senate bill 456 fn
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
we'll suppose nay
the eyes have it and senate bill 456 is
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred senate bill 381
fna
act establishing
an office of advocate for their special
education have been considered the same
report the same with the recommendations
the bill ought to pass glenn cordelli
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill be referred
the motion before us
is the majority committee report of
ought to pass on senate bill 381 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
no suppose nay
the eyes have it
the committee report is adopted and the
bill is referred to the committee on
finance
committee on education to which is
referred senate bill 420 fna local act
establishing an extraordinarily
need grant for schools having considered
the same report the same with the
following recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment presenter rick ladd for the
committee
the amendment is
1384-h printed in house record 15 page
38. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
i suppose nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
that the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
amendment on senate bill 420 fna local
are you ready for the question all those
are
represented
representative proud has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
motion before us is the motion of ought
to pass with amendment
on
senate bill 420 fna local this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you post you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative foster representative
representative
while memphis president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
261 voting yay
71 voting a
committee report is adopted
for what reason doesn't mean
and is referred to finance
i rise to make a motion
state your motion
i wish to take
the new hampshire climate action plan hb
[Music]
what was the number
hb
no
the house will be in order
we had a request for roll calls that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
for
stay tuned state your question thank you
mr speaker mr speaker this takes a
majority just to take it off the table
but does it take two-thirds to pass it
this will be a roll call vote members be
ultimately
the motion before us is to take house
bill 172 the house will be in order
172 off the table
chair recognizer representative oxenham
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that in this month
when we are facing a global
environmental crisis and an energy
crisis that no ste bills will be heard
this entire month in this house
and if i know that the intergovernmental
panel on climate change just issued a
call for urgent
immediate action
by political leaders at all levels
and if i know
it is unconscionable
that this house has not even been
a plan to study
and create a new hampshire climate
action plan
would i vote
to take hb 172 off the table by pushing
the green button
thank you
dear recognizer representative votes for
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that while the climate of our planet is
certainly changing
it is not changing in catastrophic ways
mr speaker if i also know
that the legislation
creating a climate action plan
was much too broad
and would cost our state
immense amounts of money
but i now press the red button
so that we don't remove this from the
table
the motion before us is to remove house
bill 172 from the table it's a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
152 voting a 181 voting a
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion
state your motion i'd like to take house
bill 1506 the clean energy accelerator
house will be in order what was
what was the number again
one five zero six
the question before us is to remove
house bill
1506 from the table
mr speaker i request a roll call
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
the motion before us is to remove house
bill 1506 from the table
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative williams for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the intergovernmental
panel on climate change which is a
multinational international body has
issued three reports this year regarding
the status of the world's climate
and
the circumstances that we are in
require immediate action by elected
officials across the globe
and if i know that this call to action
can be met by house bill 1506 and mr
speaker if i further know that this bill
is an energy accelerator to investigate
and research all kinds of energy
including hydrogen wind solar battery
it's completely agnostic but the goal is
to bring us into a new climate feature
and if i further know that this is an
opportunity for new hampshire to put our
toe in the sand and say this is the line
this is where we stand would i then vote
green to take this bill off the table
and support energy action here in new
hampshire thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes the rep
house will be in order
chair recognize representative votes for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that climate change is a
national and international problem
and if i further know that
new hampshire is not going to solve that
problem on its own
but i vote red to leave this bill on the
table thank you
motion before us is to remove house bill
1506 from the table this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your you're posting
press the red button voting stations are
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to state of the
vote
147 voting yay 184 voting a
house bill 1
majority committee on election law to
which was referred senate bill 242
act relative to the disqualification of
certain persons from performing the
duties of an election official
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
peter tarosian for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same as being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that it's
inexpedient to legislators in paul
bergeron for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is one three five three h
printed in house record 15 page 29. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
chair recognizes representative bergeron
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to the ought to
pass with amendment recommendation on
senate bill 242.
current statutes already prohibit all
election officials who are candidates
for another office from handling marked
ballots and counting votes
in addition any election official other
than the moderator who is a candidate
for another office is not allowed to
remain within the guard rail during the
counting of votes for an office for
which he is a candidate
this bill is amended would now prohibit
the moderator if he is a candidate for
another office from remaining in the
area designated for the counting of
votes
the problem is that this bill is in
conflict with the constitution part 2
article 32 which directs quote that
elections shall be governed by a
moderator who shall in the presence of
the selectmen receive the votes of the
inhabitants of such towns and wards
end quote
in our towns and cities choose who they
want to be their moderators for their
elections
existing statutes require that the
moderator assist in processing absentee
ballots oversee the counting of
write-ins rule on challenges of a
person's right to vote and sign the
closing paperwork and ballot box seals
by banning the moderator from the area
designated for the counting of votes the
bill essentially bans the moderator from
the polling place and prevents him from
fulfilling the responsibilities he's
required to fulfill under the state
constitution
moderators with years of service and
training are critical toward ensuring
that our polling sites are efficiently
run that elections run smoothly that
paperwork is processed properly
the ballot boxes are sealed correctly
and that the polling place is closed up
efficiently and securely
we should be trying to keep this
experience in place for state and
presidential elections not passing a law
that will require some of our towns and
wards to find substitutes to fill these
roles every other year
existing law which prohibits election
officials who appear on a ballot from
handling and counting marked ballots
sufficiently protects the integrity of
elections while allowing moderators to
fulfill the responsibilities they were
elected to form and are required to
perform by the new hampshire
constitution
please press the red no button in
opposition to the majority report of
what to pass as amended so that another
motion may be made
and mr speaker i would request a
chair recognizes representative erosion
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats we're on the
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i rise
today to speak in favor of the ought to
pass motion for senate bill 242
relative to the disqualification of
certain persons from performing the
duties of an election official
this bill is amended makes a change in
election officials duties at the polling
place when that person is a candidate on
the ballot
this legislation would provide that an
election official who is on the ballot
shall not be allowed to remain in the
area designated the counting of votes
within the guard rail during the actual
counting of votes for in office that he
or she is a candidate it doesn't prevent
them from overseeing the election
delegating to others
additionally this bill specifically
provides that an
elected
official
or
an affected official rather who cannot
go in the area where the vote of being
tabulated may be assigned other duties
by the moderator
the issue is one that comes before the
election law committee nearly every
session because of the perceived
advantage
to a candidate who can be inside the
polling place all day long
when his competitors
his or her competitors cannot
i believe that this bill strikes a
balance that
the right balance to solve this problem
once and for all
this is a
change in
this is a change that is a step in the
right direction towards leveling the
playing field for candidates
while still allowing the election
officials to be able to perform delegate
or appoint a sworn assistant to complete
their tasks and fulfill their
constitutional duties
in closing this bill as amended
provides that an election official who
is on the ballot he'll not
remain in the eerie designated
accounting post
to ensure an equal playing field for all
candidates part one article 11 of the
new hampshire constitution states every
inhabitant of the state having proper
qualifications has equal right to be
elected into office
so please press the green button
and vote yes and support the ought to
pass motion for senate bill 242. thank
you mr speaker
this is a division vote
motion before us is a majority report of
autopasses amended on senate bill 242
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative hamlet for a
thank you mr
speaker mr speaker
if i know that the new hampshire
constitution requires the moderator to
govern the entire election including the
counting of votes
and if i know that our existing laws
prohibit a moderator who is on the
ballot for another office
from handling marked ballot
and if i know that current laws are
sufficient
to govern a fair election while avoiding
the appearance of conflict
would i then press the red button to
defeat this motion
thank you mr speaker
chair recognized representative barbara
griffin for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill as amended
addresses a repeating issue that comes
before the election law committee and if
i know
that as amended the restriction on an
elected official's duties who was in the
ballot is only in regards to the
tabulation of votes
not handling
and if i further know that that elected
official has the authority specifically
in this statute and others to appoint
someone to act in their steed to ensure
that duties they're carried out
would i now press the green button to
support the recommendation of the
election law committee thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us as the majority
port of water passes amended on senate
bill 242 this is a division boat
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
okay
[Music]
that was a different form that was a
law members president opportunity vote
176 voting 851 voting nay committee
reporters adopt
members stay in your seats
the next bill
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred senate bill
365 knacked relative to absentee
ballot outer envelopes consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate senator wayne mcdonald for
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator paul bergeron from the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill would authorize
a town or city clerk to attach a voter's
absentee ballot request form and any
other required affidavits to the
absentee ballot affidavit envelope
instead of the outer return envelope and
if i know that by doing so a lot of time
will be saved at the polls on election
day because election officials will not
have to spend time tearing off the
absentee ballot request form from the
outer envelope slitting the
splitting open the outer envelopes and
then pairing the form with the affidavit
envelope and if i know that the chair of
the senate election law municipal
affairs committee noted that as long as
the ballot stays in the sealed affidavit
envelope there is no reason for the
outer envelope would i then press the
red no button in opposition to the
majority report of an expedient to
legislate so that another motion may be
made
chair recognizes representative mcdonald
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the state of
new hampshire has encountered legal
challenges as a result of those persons
with print disabilities being easily
able to vote and a possibility exists
with this bill
that the accompanying affidavit required
from the person who assisted them with
their ballot could get misplaced during
pre-processing thus creating further
legal issues for the state
and mr speaker if i know any absentee
ballot envelopes open prior to election
day pose potential security concerns
and mr speaker if i know that depending
on when absentee ballots might be
returned all voters would not have an
equal opportunity to cure the defects of
their ballots during pre-processing mr
speaker if i know all of these things
will i then press the green button and
vote this bill in expedient to legislate
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is a majority
committee reporter in expeditionary
legislative senate bill 2365.
this is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
opposed to press the red button voting
homework is president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
184 voting yeah 146 14a the committee
majority committee on election law to
which was referred senate bill 418 fn
act relative to verification of voter
affidavits considered the same report
the same with the following amendment
the recommendation of the bill auto
password amendment and a rosberry for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate president of
connie lane for the minority of the
committee the amendment is 1487h printed
in house record 15 page 37. the question
before you was on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
north opposed nay
the eyes have it committee amendment is
adopted
the chair recognizes
representative
thank you mr speaker
this bill in the name of election
integrity establishes affidavit
balloting
also known as provisional
or challenge ballots
despite any evidence of any abuse of our
existing system under current laws
the bill removes the ability of a voter
without photo identification
to sign an affidavit
at the voting place swearing to the
voter's address and identity
and replaces it with a provisional
ballot
that is set aside
and only counted if the race is close
and after going through an ill-defined
confirmation process
which is both
expensive and complicated
in addition to being a thinly veiled
voter suppression effort
the bill is riddled with serious flaws
including a question as to whether it
violates the new hampshire constitution
part 2
article 32
by adding or subtracting votes
after the tally is made by the moderator
on election night
a second major flaw
is that provisional ballots are not
secret
they are assigned a number linking them
to the voter
the moderator and other voting officials
will be able to see the provisional
ballot linked to a voter
furthermore this bill in
directly conflicts with new hampshire
rsa 656-16
which provides that there shall be no
impression or mark to distinguish one
general election ballot from another
under this bill the affidavit is marked
by the moderator
next the bill endangers new hampshire's
exemption from the national voter
registration act
the loss of which would require an
overhaul of our entire voting system
with an estimated cost of 6.5 million
dollars
in cities and towns with many new voters
the impact of this bill on the voting
system will be severe
requiring additional staff and training
for election workers
on top of all of this despite the
amended time frames in the bill
it will be exceedingly difficult if not
impossible for the secretary of state to
comply with the uniformed and overseas
citizens absentee voting act
which requires that ballots go out to
our service members and their families
45 days prior to the election
finally
one of the reasons that we have been
able to retain the first in the nation
primary status is because of same-day
registration and the lack of provisional
ballots
this bill will further endanger our
retention of the first in the nation's
status
in a close race it will take at least a
week
to determine a winner
because of these seven serious flaws in
sb
418 the minority opposes the motion of
ought to pass as amended thank you
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise today again to speak
in favor of the majority motion of
autopass for senate bill 418.
this is an act relative to verification
of voter affidavits for verification of
voter affidavits today under current law
anybody can come to new hampshire going
into a polling place on election day
fill out a same-day registration form
put down a local address without any id
they can vote as long as they fill out
an affidavit form
as you know in new hampshire we don't
currently require an individual to
present any form of identification if
you fill out the affidavit form
you will
you can then leave the polling place or
the state for that matter
and by the time anybody might question
whether or not the affidavit was valid
the election process would be over the
vote count complete in any legitimate
vote
would not be changed
now some will say that it is a burden to
have to show an id to vote
mr speaker this is 2022
you need an id to register your car
register your dog take money out of the
bank buy a house rent a house buy
alcohol cigarettes
fly on an airplane pick up your kids at
daycare and on and on mr speaker would
you believe
that a bank would not loan you money to
buy a car
without checking your valid id not even
and even if you sign an affidavit they
still want to see the id
this legislation before us as amended is
a solution to an overwhelming request
from new hampshire citizens to ensure
that all people voting in new hampshire
are doing so as
as legal voters in their city or town
when i travel out of the area to other
states
and mention that i'm from new hampshire
oftentimes i hear people say
oh i've heard of new hampshire that's a
place you can show up vote
well under this proposed legislation
same-day registrants that come to the
polls without a valid photo id will be
quiet to vote by affidavit ballot
senate bill 418 as amended would require
for all elections if a vote on election
day is registering to vote for the first
time
does not have a valid photo
identification establishing such voters
identity or does not meet the identity
requirement of rsa 659 colon 13
then such voter shall vote by affidavit
valid
this new provision
requires the affidavit of said voter to
be returned with missing voter
qualification documents within seven
days to the secretary of state either in
person or by mail
if the voter fails to comply and does
not prove their identity within the
seven day window then the secretary of
state will instruct the moderator of the
affected town or district to count
any of these unqualified ballots using
the same method used for hand counting
ballots on election day the votes cast
on such unqualified
affidavit ballots shall be deducted from
the total
for each affected candidate this
legislation contrary to some rumors
circulating out there will not affect
any ukava ballots or military cast
ballots in any way
as a united states coast guard veteran i
would never support any legislation that
would restrict voting of our military
and in fact without them we may not even
have the right to vote
the majority finds us to be a fair and
reasonable solution to voter integrity
issues and the best way to restore voter
confidence to our citizens
confidence in the election process is at
an all-time low which which does hurt
and somewhat suppresses the turnout
throughout the state
the stronger voter confidence the more
likely
you are to come out and vote which in
turn increases voter turnout as the
confidence is regained
please press the green button and vote
yes for restoring voter confidence
to new hampshire residents closing the
no id loophole
chair recognized representative moorhead
thank you mr speaker
sb 418
is an expensive and complicated solution
to a problem
the new hampshire secretary of state
says that elections in new hampshire
are free
fair
trustworthy
that they're not marred by fraud
and that they have all the integrity
that we could ever hope elections to
possess
here in new hampshire
governor sununu
said
our elections are secure
accurate
and reliable
there is governor sununu said
the right thing to do
is to follow the example of governor
sununu
and our secretary of state
and tell
voters
instead of this
this bill from the other body indulges
misinformation
political scientists
have shown that the problem with
elections
in the united states is not that
citizens vote
more than once
but that many citizens
encounter too many obstacles to
exercising their right to vote at all
the problem empirically
is not fraudulent turnout
but low turnout
and that's why legislators
in the republican party
and in the democratic party
for 35 years
following the voting rights act of 1965
tried to address low turnout by removing
impediments
to accessing the ballot it was only
after the almost tied election of 2000
that some cynical strategists came to
the belief that the best way to win
elections was not by persuading voters
but by discouraging voters
and this has led us away from the
turnout question to endlessly chasing
the ghost of election fraud
does not solve
any existing problems but it does
create some real new it would create
real new problems here's just one
it creates two classes of voters
when somebody if this bill were to pass
more than 30 days prior to an election
they prove their citizenship
by signing
the voter registration form
which contains an affidavit in which
they attest to being citizens of the
united states that's how they prove
their citizenship
but somebody who registers to vote on
voting day
for this bill to pass would have to
offer a passport
or
a birth certificate
to prove their citizenship
so we're creating two classes of voters
one that proved their citizenship by
signing an affidavit and another they
have to prove it by producing a passport
that costs more than a hundred dollars
to procure that many citizens don't
possess or by producing a birth
certificate
that many many people don't have ready
access to many people don't have ready
access to their original embossed and
stamped birth certificate and many
do not carry it with them
when they go to vote
so we have two classes of voters with
different burdens
for proving their citizenship that is
wrong
and it will i think
i predict be declared unconstitutional
citizens should have the same
requirements to prove their eligibility
eligibility to vote
no matter when they register to vote
sb 418 violates that
for this reason as well as the broad
effect of sb 418 on ballot access
i urge this body
we're on to the final speaker a division
has been requested
members will take their seats chair
recognizes representative berry
thank you uh mr speaker i'll be brief
so i always like to start off the
election law
speeches with reminding the body just
what is required to vote in the state of
new hampshire
it's nothing
it's nothing you have to produce nothing
you sign an affidavit it's a piece of
paper it means nothing
opponents of this say the affidavit has
merit five thousand dollar penalty you
can go to jail
real that's awesome
track that person down when they've
given you a fake name and a fake address
and to take them to jail
it's a laughable system
what we did mr speaker with the
amendment that this body passed is we
scoped this bill down to address people
that are showing up to the polling
location on election day who are not
registered to vote
and are registering to vote with nothing
they are presenting nothing to show who
they are who they say they are
mr speaker
i have never claimed that there's
massive voter fraud in the state of new
hampshire i've never made that claim
i have said from the beginning in fact
the first speech i ever gave to this
body was that new hampshire has a
serious problem with lack of faith in
the elections i cited a
saint anselm's poll at the time that
showed that only 63 percent of granite
staters were extremely confident in the
outcome of an election
so while we while the minority party
speaks of turnout
let me be very clear
new hampshire republicans are not afraid
of high voter turnout we just won an
election with the highest turnout ever
we're not afraid of it what we want to
know
is that people who are going to the
polls
are who they say they are
this is a compromise
off of the original bill
mr speaker i'll end with this
if we have concerns about turnout
those turnouts in my opinion
are low because of a lack of a faith in
the elections because we have a process
that while we can have a debate to the
extent it's being abused because there's
no debate that it's being abused because
we've prosecuted it
but mr speaker people who have don't
have faith in the elections don't vote
if you want to increase voter turnout
which republicans do
give the people a system that they can
have faith in and that's what this does
thank you mr speaker
does the member yield the questions
remember it does not yield
roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats this is a roll call
vote
the motion before us
the majority report of auto passes
amended on senate bill 418.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative lane for
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill attempts to discourage voting by
establishing provisional balloting which
identifies a voter's ballot
sets it aside to be counted only if
needed
and if a complicated process is followed
by the voter
and that it will delay a final tally for
seven to ten days if utilized
if i know
there are significant questions as to
whether the bill violates new hampshire
constitution part two rule i'm sorry
article 32
and rsa 656-16
and if i know that this bill makes it
exceedingly difficult
for the secretary of state to comply
with the uniformed and overseas citizens
absentee voting act
thereby endangering the ability of our
service members and their families to
vote
then i would press the red button to
defeat this motion so that another
motion may be brought forward thank you
chair i recognize remember barbara
griffin for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill as amended
continues to allow all persons who come
to a polling place on election day to
cast a ballot
and if mr speaker if i know that this
bill does not address citizenship but
addresses the issue of positive
identification a requirement in voting
which has been upheld as legal across
the country
and if i know that it provides for
meaningful verification of that id
within seven days of the election and
that in 2020 there were 733 persons who
voted in this state with no
identification and that follow-up action
by the secretary of state resulted in
260 of those being unable to be verified
or located in the state
and finally mr speaker if i know that
this would have no adverse effect on
yukaba voters as the time period
originally proposed in this bill has
been decreased to seven days and the
secretary of state's office has
indicated that it's adequate time to
deal with the issuance of those ballots
would i now press the green button to
support the recommendation of the
committee thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto pass as amended on senate
bill
418 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
under an 80 voting yeah 154 voting a the
committee report is adopted
bill is referred to the committee on
finance
everybody will stay in their seats we
got two quick bills and then we're going
to take the lunch break
majority committee on election law to
which was referred house bill senate
bill 425 fn act relative to the
establishment of an election in
informational portal considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpensive
to legislate
representative ross berry from the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report with a recommendation that bill
ought to pass representative paul
bergeron from the minority of the
committee the most the question before
us is
the
majority committee report of
inexpediential legislation senate bill
425 fn are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
that's opposed
nay the eyes have it the committee
members be in your seats this
next bill is a division with just pis
the majority of the committee on
election law to which was referred
senate bill 427 fn
enact modifying the absentee voter
registration process absentee ballot
application an absentee ballot voting
process having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that has been
expedient to legislative president wayne
mcdonald for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate of connie lane from the
minority of the committee
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative lane for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that being sick or having a
mental condition medical condition can
be actual reasons why a voter cannot get
to a polling place
if i know that the secretary of state
and the attorney general recognized this
fact during the 2020 elections and
expanded the definition of disability to
include illness and mental conditions
and medical conditions
as legitimate reasons for requesting an
absentee ballot
and
if i know
that this bill if passed will allow more
people to vote
then would i then would i press the red
button to vote against the motion for
itl so that a new motion can be brought
forward thank you
chair recognizes representative mcdonald
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill adds
circumstances as a basis under which
someone can vote absentee
which are vague undefined and open-ended
mr speaker if i know that the greater
the volume of absentee ballots the
greater the risk there is of error and
inaccuracy in the final vote count
as was seen in a number of communities
during the 2020 election
and mr speaker
if i know that this bill exceeds the
constitutional allowance for absentee
voting and the current reasons to allow
for absentee voting are sufficient
if i know all of this mr speaker then i
would would i then press the green
button and vote this bill in expedient
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpedient to
legislate on senate bill 427
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president an opportunity to
183 voting a 151 voting a committee
representative hill has a
good morning good afternoon
could i ask the committee members of
legislative administration to meet under
we will reconvene
please
members take their seats we're going to
here recognizes representative rhodes
stage of motion
mr speaker i would like to make a motion
for the gentleman to be able to take off
their coats and for people to be able to
gentlemen to be able to take off their
jackets and people to be able to take
off their masks
oh
committee on environment agriculture
which was referred senate bill 267 fna
an act establishing the upland invasive
species program
program fund program coordinator in the
department of
agriculture markets and food having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment
the amendment is one four four one h
printed in house record 15 page 29. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye
that was opposed nay
the amendment passes the question before
you now is
the
committee amendment of ought to pass
with amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those pose nay
the eyes have it
and senate bill 267 is referred to the
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration the house
majority committee on executive
departments administration to which was
referred senate bill 438 fn local
an act establishing state procurement
policies intended to promote the use of
american materials have been considered
the same report the same with the
following amendment
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with amendment
representative
jc grote for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same to be an honorable
degree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator matthew
sanotosto for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is 1422 h printed in house
record 15 page 49
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the chair recognizes representatives on
the pasto
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
this pill represents the economic
ignorance in our society today
economists from different schools of
thought debate constantly on a lot of
topics
however they don't debate on
protectionism they agree that
protectionism is harmful and that its
costs outweigh the benefits and that it
impedes economic growth
this protectionist bill will force
taxpayers to subsidize local businesses
it will increase the cost of government
one rationale for protectionism is to
level the playing field this idea
suggests that because other countries
subsidize their industry we must do
something to make it equal
this pinpoints one tiny tiny area of
unfairness and ignores that the world is
infinitely complex there are so many
inputs into the production of a good
like steel
we would need to check if any of the
inputs for us steel
have any other fair advantages in the
trucking or the trade schools for the
laborers or environmental compliance
rules or safety compliance or countless
other areas
there's always advantages and
disadvantages to do one thing in one
place or another where does it end if
somebody tried to grow bananas in new
hampshire should we also sub-size them
due to the unfairness
with regions that have climates more
suitable for this
we should allow the market to find areas
of strength in our side this is known as
comparative advantage
investopedia.com defines comparative
advantage as an economy's ability to
produce a particular good or service
at a lower opportunity cost
than its trading partners
comparative advantage is used to explain
why companies countries or individuals
can benefit from trade
additionally other countries economic
interventions does not actually give
them an advantage
in the case of candidates applies power
and health care to its industry
it's not cheaper for canada to levy
attacks on its citizens to cover
electrical power than for a private
company to directly pay for the power
these costs don't magically go away
because the government is covering them
however if it is that canada or anyone
else is subsidizing their exports or
otherwise under pricing their goods we
should actually be happy to take
advantage of the situation
we should allow canada to subsidize our
public work projects and thank them for
the favor
another concern is we need to stop the
money from floating out of the united
states
this type of thinking is a confusion
between money and wealth it's important
to understand that money is a unit of
account and not wealth
all things being equal the amount of
money flowing around the united states
doesn't affect the economy per se
it would only affect the price of things
nominally besides the united states is
experiencing 8.5 inflation so it might
be good to export some more cash in that
regard
the principle of the scene and the
unseen
government policy only focuses on the
scene while ignoring the unseen
in this case we want to protect the jobs
of steel workers
it's true this legislation will benefit
that special interest and they will
maintain workers this is the scene
one unseen consequence of this is the
now higher labor costs will cause other
businesses to fail however no one will
able to connect the dots and prove that
this struggle is impart affected by this
legislation
this kind of thing causes countless
unseen ripples throughout the economy
the labor market today is weak anyways
since protections
since protectionism has been known by
academics for centuries to be
destructive then why does it
continuously become law
it's for the same reason that only
people who are for the bill showed up to
test the testimony
the principle of concentrated benefits
and diffuse costs
provides that the individual costs to
each taxpayer is so low that it's not
worth the effort to fight the new law
but the benefit is so high for the steel
producers that it is worth the effort to
fight for the law
imagine a bill that transfers one
million dollars to a single individual
per year
he has a good incentive to fight for
this
and let's say it will cost 100 million
people one penny per year
these people have no incentive to fight
against the law
this principle applies here
protectionist policies don't protect the
industry it intends to and hurts our
national defense
the jones act that requires u.s flag
ships to transport goods between u.s
ports
caused between 2000 and 2016
the fleet of private sector jones act
ships fell from 193 to 91.
these u.s flagships are completely
uncompetitive in international shipping
this shipping protectionism is the root
is a root cause for poverty in puerto
rico
it's cheaper for the island to import
goods internationally than to comply
with the jones act and import from the
united states
our nation is completely reliant on
international shipping to function
weakening our national defense
besides national defense and homeland
security combined consume only three
percent of american steel
eighteen percent of the imported steel
come from canada
how would a canadian steel canadian made
steel being a problem for american
security
much of the remaining imports especially
in the case of steel
uh
originate from american allies
seventy percent of the steel used in the
us is produced domestically
our national security is not threatened
by imported steel
please vote with me against the
committee report to avoid putting this
economic ignorance into law
thank you mr speaker does the member
yield the questions
yes
thank you mr speaker thank you
representative for taking my question
i i wouldn't ask if you would agree that
if we pass protective protectionist
legislation like this it only encourages
the protected industry to be less
competitive to stop seeking out new and
innovative ways to make their product
better and cheaper because they don't
uh yes that's exactly correct without uh
without international pressure to force
um companies to innovate and to to
produce goods at you know better quality
and lower cost um
you know they're gonna it's gonna be a
worse product i like to think about
brazil in the 1980s they
had massive protectionist rules against
the electronics computers and software
and because of this a brazilian fax
machine cost five to ten thousand
dollars
and uh the protocol was proprietary to
brazil so no other factory in the world
was even compatible with it um so these
kind of protect and now they don't have
any industry really in the
microprocessor space because they
destroyed it with their protectionism
remember yield to a further question
thank you mr speaker thank you
representative for taking uh my question
would you believe that the
implication
of tariffs and other
protective strategies for u.s industries
actually hurt u.s industries
a case in point i work for a
manufacturing company in manchester we
import steel and aluminum from um
primarily from from europe it's
specialty material and that when the
when the tariffs were passed to protect
u.s steel and aluminum it caused your
representative you were you know for a
question that the domestic supply simply
increases prices to match those and
really the only outcome is the end
consumer has to spend more money to get
what they need
uh yes that's correct the domestic
product would be priced to uh consume
the
the price of the empire product plus
tariff
thank you mr speaker thank you
colleagues i um
i didn't have anything else to wear
today
so this bill states that
for projects over one million dollars
the state will use american-made steel
with few exceptions
when budweiser came to merrimack or or
when walmart came to raymond
those specific corporations received tax
incentives to come to new hampshire
this bill is not a subsidy to any
specific corporation
all steel fabricators will continue to
have to bid
for these projects
the state has the right
to go with foreign steel
if it is in the best interest of the
state that is in the bill
23 states already have america first
programs
of one type or another including alabama
indiana oklahoma and texas
currently there is a federal tariff on
steel but the chinese figured out a way
around the tariff
they simply drill a small hole in the
metal
now it is considered processed steel
they drill a hole
it's a literal loophole in the tariff
law
this makes it difficult for new
hampshire steel fabricators to compete
on a level playing field
the chairman of the state procurement
commission
is a co-sponsor of this bill i sit on
this commission
and find that it does not place an undue
burden on the state at all
this bill
will help level the playing field i ask
for your support for this bipartisan
bill to end the unfair advantage on
foreign steel thank you mr speaker
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to this bill and
the reasons i'll give are are principled
and practical i'll start out with the
principal
uh
reasons and that is that
as has been stated protectionism
does not work in the long run
in this if this bill is is
passed
it will affect a very small very small
segment of the u.s manufacturing
segment
and
that manufacturing segment does not have
the capacity does not have the capacity
to produce enough steel for our needs in
the united states
could it come to that point over a long
period of time yes but not in the short
term it also impacts a very very small
segment of our new hampshire businesses
four maybe five
significant fabricators of steel
in my
business outside of this
legislature
i'm a general contractor and i'll give
you an example of a project that we have
going
in rochester right now
this project will use somewhere between
two point five and three million dollars
structural steel
it is not a municipal product
project excuse me so
it would not be impacted by this bill
but i'm i'm
using the project as an illustration if
this were a municipal project and it
could very easily be it's it's
comparable to others
this project would be delayed
by a minimum of a year
if this bill applied
the bar joists that will be used in that
building which are part of the
structural steel are primarily produced
in canada
the manufacturers here in new hampshire
don't have the capability of producing
that currently the backlog on bar joists
is eight months to a year if we made
this american steel it would be two to
three years
we would simply not be able to produce
it i could go
to other aspects of the structural steel
in that building
how would this affect
our
businesses within new hampshire
if we said that
the product had to be purchased using
american steel on the one hand
yes it would prevent
the import of canadian or
or chinese steel or western european
steel
but
what it would also do
is it dries up the source of steel for
these manufacturers for these
fabricators
and we use these fabricators we try to
use them every instance we can or new
hampshire fabricators
but they would not be able to purchase
the steel this bill says that the steel
needs to be produced in the u.s from
melting from melting
through finished product including the
coatings including all the components of
it everything
if the steel has to be produced from
iron ore in the united states and our
plants our steel plants do not have the
capacity and they do not have the
capacity it will delay municipal product
projects and if the answer is well we'll
just give them a waiver why are we
putting in a bill that we're going to
give everybody waivers for because
otherwise the project will be delayed a
year
that doesn't quite make sense
on the
other side of it as far as again just
the principled application
if this is to apply to structural steel
that is again a very tiny component of
the steel industry of steel usage in the
u.s
if this applies just to structural steel
why not protect
steel in dishwashers microwaves bed
frames nails bolts
etc etc door springs
why wouldn't we say in a in a new
hampshire building a new hampshire
municipal building that it has to cover
all those items and then
if we say that it's fair to protect them
why would we not perfect protect our
lumber mills in the u.s and say nope all
the lumber in the building has to be
that and i'll tell you why we wouldn't
do it because it would be a disaster for
us
because we do not have the capacity to
produce that
you might think i'm up here
arguing against our manufacturing i am
totally in support of united states
manufacturing i think we should do
everything in our power to increase that
but the best way to increase that is to
encourage competitiveness
and part of that is by reducing
unreasonable regulations that literally
plague our industries
this bill
if passed
will not do what it's intended to do
it will in fact i believe harm the very
industry that it's intended to protect
i would urge you
to vote
red
on this committee amendment so an
alternate alternate
the chair recognizes representative
grote for
this is the last speaker
a division has been requested members
thank you mr speaker we'll get to the
roll call in a minute
house bill 438
is not as complicated
as one will lead to believe listening to
our previous speakers
house bill 438 requires the state
to use american
in in-state agency projects
for those projects that exceed a million
dollars
so that would be for road construction
for road projects bridges
can you not hear me
okay
there are
at least four steel fabricators in
america in new hampshire
that could use this
legislation
to quote on jobs
these are small private
companies
and as i've stood here
to listen to all of us for the last four
years
all small businesses in new hampshire
there are four waivers
for this
for a company
to
not be to have an exception of using
a
uh owl structure at all american steel
the first one has to do with the ability
to meet specifications
if the fabricator cannot meet the
specifications required for the project
there
their quote is not considered
if a
fabricator is unable to meet the
deadline
due to delays in shipping
their their quote does not need to be
considered
if a
manufacturer is unable to meet the
design requirements their waiver can
also be
deleted
and lastly there's a consideration for
costs as well
so i encourage you to support this
bipartisan bill
and support the committee
roll call has been requested by
lieutenant sylvia
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the majority
report a lot of passes amended on senate
bill 438 this is going to be a roll call
vote
the chair recognizes representative
you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know i like steele
and mr speaker i really like u.s steel
but mr speaker i also like free market
principles
under senate bill
there would be a special interest carve
out
for steel producers for any public
project costing
a million dollars or more
but not for projects costing 999
thousand
this this is a pi representative correct
go figure
if i know
this is a subsidy for local businesses
which will force taxpayers to pay more
mr speaker i buy local whenever i can
but i don't think we
should force our citizens to pay more
for construction based on the cost of a
particular building
hence driving up the cost and creating a
supply shortage
and finally mr speaker this bill places
u.s manufacturers in a special class
contrary to the constitution part 1
article 10. again this is a
parliamentary inquiry right therefore
would i now press the red button to
overturn the otpa motion so another
motion can be made
next time i'll put a few more i knows in
there
chair recognizing representative marsh
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know foreign subsidized steel has
been stealing american jobs for decades
and if i have seen the devastating
effects on communities when these
well-paying blue-collar jobs are lost
forever
and if i know the time is now to keep
good jobs in new hampshire
would i not push
the green button and support the
bipartisan 13-5 committee report and
adopt this bill thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of what a pass has amended on
senate bill 438
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
170 voting yay 151 voting a committee
and it is uh referred to the fine
have declared a conflict of interest and
majority of the committee on health
human services and elderly faster which
was referred senate bill 403
fna
enact reestablishing the special
supplemental nutrition program for women
imprints children
farmers market nutrition program having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass soon as lieutenant dennis acton
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study and of erica
lay on for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative leon to
thank you mr speaker
this bill will give thirty dollars to
approximately ten thousand wic
recipients to use at farmers markets at
a cost of thirty thousand dollars and a
quarter of a full-time employee
this bill would let disadvantaged
families spend six five dollar coupons
at farmers markets
exposing them to the offerings of a
great environment which is unfortunately
the most expensive way to buy local
produce
and then leaving them unable to build a
habit of buying local produce at the
farmers market they'll still be able to
buy produce and even new hampshire
produce at the grocery store with their
existing benefits
this is a federal solution
and i know that new hampshire can craft
a better solution
everybody on the committee wants to make
sure that new hampshire produce makes
its way to new hampshire plates
especially for our neediest families
i think we can solve some of these
problems
food waste especially imperfect produce
reduces the available supply
if you had a chance to get some of that
produce would you buy it i know i would
csas are community supported agriculture
they provide consistency and schedule
throughout the growing season and they
expose people to the cycle of crops here
in new hampshire
can we offer a tax credit to offer this
to our wic families or other low-income
families
can we make it so those families visit
this farm
and see where the food they get to eat
has grown
can we do this better in new hampshire
i think we can
i think new hampshire can lead the way
for this country in ways to find
innovative solutions to deliver our
produce to our people that's why i ask
you to oppose the the otp motion so that
another motion can be made and we can
seize on the opportunity to discuss this
during the growing season and find a new
hampshire solution
as the member yield the questions
i i thank the gentlelady for the taking
the question um you
said that you made a
actual claim that actually surprised me
um since i'm a reg i'm a pretty cheap
guy and i'm also a regular
um attendee of my local farmers market
um is that in fact the most expensive
way to buy local produce because it
seems to me
i always seems to me the uh
excuse me you're buying directly from
the growers so at least that should make
it cheaper so so
thank you for the question when the
farmers need to bring the produce to the
farmers market
take time away from the farm in order to
bring it to a location with a chance for
waste
with a chance for waste for the unsold
product
this is more expensive than them working
with a csa or another thing where they
another opportunity where they could
deliver it to low-income communities in
order for that to be directly
distributed to these families
we have a chance to let these families
see the cycle of local agriculture to
get this food delivered to their
communities and find a way to support
this within our state
i think we can do better than just
starting a small program that builds up
a large bureaucracy to support a future
program that we may or may not choose to
accept and i think new hampshire can do
chair recognizing representative acton
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker sb 403 is a bill that
reestablishes the wic farmers market
nutrition program
this program is sponsored by the fda and
aims to assist low-income women infants
and children up to age five by providing
nutritious foods and information on
healthy eating
the bill adds a new section to rsa 132
which states
that the program shall distribute food
instruments in this case vouchers or
credits
to eligible wic participants to redeem
for locally grown fresh fruits
vegetables and
herbs at authorized
new hampshire farmers markets
there are two goals that in my mind
justify supporting this bill first by
providing the ability for low-income
families
to buy nutritious locally grown foods
we can help build long-term
habits that support healthy lifestyles
this can help reduce the long-term
health care expenses that are incurred
by the medicaid program
each child in the program will receive a
credit of thirty dollars once a year
that will allow their family to attend
the farmers market and make purchases
i took part in a similar program last
year
where veterans were given a 20 credit
and that was each weekend over the
summer so my wife and i would go to the
market and
uh we would take advantage of the 20
dollar credit and we would wind up
leaving with a you know quite a
we use our own money and you know we
basically it
helped build a habit of actually going
to the farmers market rather than just
down to the store
secondly this program will provide much
needed revenue to new hampshire-based
farmers at a crucial time
when we need to build local capacity in
response to the collapsing
when the program was operating in the
past
farmers taking part in the local markets
around the state reported they saw an
increase in sales
that would have gone into purchasing
processed foods
where produce trucked in from mexico or
flown in from overseas
so in conclusion it becomes quite
apparent that we face a food supply
crisis the likes that pretty much not
it it is our responsibility to prepare
for such a disaster by making sure that
our farmers here in the state
can produce the food we need and our
citizens have the knowledge of how to
access these locally grown foods
re-establishing the wic farmers market
program is necessary step into in making
sure there will we are building the
capacity we need to prepare for possible
tough times ahead
thank you
does the member yield the questions uh
yes remember yields
thank you to the gentleman for taking my
question
if new hampshire were to create its own
program would hampshire not have to put
the bill for the administration and all
the costs of this program rather than
utilizing existing federal dollars that
have already been raised and
appropriated for states having these
programs
okay so the breakdown
goes and
according to the fiscal note
the
the state
pay will will pay defenders match 10 10
and the state will
match another 20 dollars to make that
30. that's once a year
also on the um
as far as the
full the requirements what they call the
the fet the full-time equivalent is only
0.25
so this doesn't isn't going to take a
full-time employee it's going to take
about 12 and a half hours
a week out of someone's
time to admit administer this the
farmers markets in new hampshire are are
well run well established and have been
actually very successful for years and
years and i i see that
by enabling wic again will help build on
mr member yielded further questions
remember yields inquire
uh thank you mr speaker thank you for
taking my question you spoke about a 20
veterans credit last year and it came
week after week
and established a habit of going to the
farmers market
how would that
how would this one-time 30 dollars
the the veterans program was paid
not
through the
federal system i believe i
i'm not sure exactly the funding system
that was for uh but that was a very
generous benefit that was being provided
probably by private donors um
30 bucks a year is not much
for family with three kids you know it's
starting to get a little bit better so
in essence it's a little bit more
symbolic but it allows
families that normally would
probably not even have the time to even
worry about a farmers market exposes
them to that let them know where it is
and how to get there and see what's
available
and um it's just a basically an
introduction into that system so it's a
foot in the door it'll be an annual
program that goes on year and year so so
yeah i mean
it would be better if we had more money
to put in
for this uh certainly the
food inflation is going to be a problem
for
years
but i think here we should take what we
get in to
prepare for shortages coming
thank you
so member yield of further questions
thank you mr speaker thank you for
taking my question i'm just curious on
this the bill it talks about a local uh
farmers markets within the state so i
assume it's limited to farmers markets
in new hampshire how do we know the
produce that that market comes from if
new hampshire is grown in new hampshire
is there anything that stops someone
from simply
a farmer going to maine saying i don't
have enough tomatoes this week so i'm
going to go over there and buy a bunch
and bring them over and sell them also
uh the
the group that organizes farmers markets
um do a very good job of keeping the
keeping things organized they know who's
who's part of this
uh they're very prominent farms in our
communities in our towns and um
so it's unlikely that someone would be
able to come in and dupe them into
pulling in
main produce or
stuff that they bought at market bask
and turn around and sell it very
unlikely that would happen because it's
get here
for what reason is it memorized for a
motion mr speaker state your motion mr
speaker i'd like to make a motion to
it is a proper motion so the motion
a division has been requested
[Music]
the motion before us is the table house
bill a senate bill 403 members will be
chair recognizes representative bel
disarro thank you mr parliamentary
inquiry mr speaker if i know that i
wanted to sit here and listen to the
debate on this bill
and if i believe
that what i heard today there's so much
confusion on this bill
that we need to table this bill and
maybe rethink it
then
would i vote
green and table this bill thank you
chair recognizes representative weber
okay thank you mr speaker
if i know
that a bill
that provides fresh local produce
to
women and children
and if i know that a bill
that provides
extra support
for our local farmers
is a win-win
and
if i know that our local farmers at our
local farmers market know exactly where
everybody else's produce comes from
would i now oppose the tabling motion
the motion before us is the table senate
bill 403 this is going to be a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're posting press the
red button voting stations are open for
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote state will the house
168 voting a 158 voting a senate bill
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly fears to
which was referred senate bill 407 fn
act relative to
expanding medicaid to include certain
postpartum health care services and
making an appropriation therefore
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass so jerry can arch from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
following resolution resolve that as
the bill on second reading open to
further
floor amendment
representative cole fault offers floor
amendment one five nine one h it's in
your seat pockets
here recognizes representative cole
fault
senate bill 407
extends postpartum benefits under our
state's medicaid program
from a current period of 60 days
to an entire year
and although i think this is a very
laudable goal
it does so at the expense of adding yet
another straw to the camel's back of
government spending
the amendment before you is intended to
address what i believe is the most
sb 407
takes advantage of a provision in the
and under that under that act there are
federal matching funds
to co-fund
this extension of postpartum benefits
for states that adopt it
there is however a catch
and the catch is that the federal
funding expires after five years
if you look closely at senate bill 407
you will notice that there is no such
expiration
the amendment before you simply adds a
provision that when the federal funding
when the federal matching funds expire
this program too will expire
mr speaker i ask my colleagues to cast a
vote for produce and fiscal
responsibility by supporting this
motion before us is the cobalt floor
are you ready for the question this is
a division has been requested members
i've already put the question forward as
the motion before us is the cold fault
floor amendment 1591-h
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
all members president opportunity vote
179 voting 848 voting a
the co fault amendment is adopted
the motion before us now
is the majority report of ought to pass
as amended on senate bill 407
who requested a roll call from silvia
requested a roll call if that's
officially seconded
yes it is sufficiently seconded this
the motion before us
is ought to pass as amended
this is going to be a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
set
had an opportunity to vote also attend
212 voting yay 117 voting a committee
i'll still be in order awful noisy
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs to which was
senate bill 416 relative to behavioral
health assessment and treatment for
children in out of home placements
representative weber moves ought to pass
and offers floor amendments
one six six eight
and she's recognized to speak to a
motion
ah
the question is on the amendment are you
i'm sorry that caught me unawares
the
reason this came out of our committee as
we had without recommendation is we had
a very long day
and when the
sponsor of the bill in the senate
brought us the bill she also brought us
several suggestions
that she thought would clarify the bill
and as it was clear when she was
presenting them to the committee that
they appeared to be acceptable
to the committee
i obtained an amendment
that had
those changes but we didn't vote on the
bill right away
and then it was a long day
and we never got to vote on that
amendment so that's why we are here
without amendment
without recommendation rather but
what the amendment does is it simply
makes some minor clarifications to the
bill
the purpose of the bill is to make very
sure
that we only send kids out of state
for out-of-state placements when they
are completely and utterly
necessary and there's adequate clinical
documentation
that
that is
the only
way that a child receives the treatment
that they need
because as we all know keeping kids here
is not only the right thing to do
because it keeps them closer to their
homes and their families
it's also a lot less expensive
so
the changes
uh
were that they made it clear that these
that a behavioral
analysis assessment is only going to be
done
when clinically necessary
the further change
allocates the responsibility for doing
that behavioral assessment
to the school if existing law already
requires the school to do that
behavioral assessment
and to the department in cases where the
school is not required to do the
assessment
so it really is just a clarification and
then it changed the word individual to
individuals so that
assessments might be done by more than
one person when they needed to happen so
i urge the amendment on all of you and
urge you to vote yes thank you
question before us
is the
representative weber floor amendment 166
8 h are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
question before us now is ought to pass
as amended
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
both opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs to which was
referred senate bill 430 fna neck
relative to health and human
health and human services having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment recommendation
that bill autopats would amendment it's
in beth folsom for the committee
the amendment is 1484-h
printed in house record 15 pages 39-49
the question before you is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed may
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now
is ought to pass as amended
chair recognizes representative andres
thank you mr speaker
i just learned a little while ago
because i did some more reading that
this bill
was presented on the behalf of dhhs
today i would like
to say a few words about senate bill
430.
this omnibus bill in my opinion
is complicated
and will be a burden to the taxpayers of
this bill had 22 parts
and then was broken down into 74
sections
for the fiscal impact as follows
now i broke down the impact that was
giving because i am a bookkeeper by
trade and we're always asking questions
21 sections
of this bill
had no fiscal impact
42 sections had minimal fiscal impact
which is impossible to imagine
what does a total
minimal
fiscal impact
mean
for 42 sections of this bill i mean does
it mean
50 000
50 million dollars 2 million i mean we
absolutely have no idea of this minimal
impact
seven sections were listed as fiscal
impact was indeterminable
and four sections of the bill were
estimated 2.8 million would come from a
general fund appropriation
29 000 and 700 000 would be appropriated
in fiscal year 23.
we have no real absolute figures of
estimates as to the total cost of this
bill
the new hampshire constitution part 2
article 5 states in part
and this is talking about our powers
and father
full power
and authority i hereby given
and granted to the said general court
from time to time to make
ordain and establish all manner
of wholesome
and reasonable orders
laws
statutes ordinances directions and
instructions
is
sb 430
wholesome and reasonable
does sb 430 go against the state
constitution
the pill the bill is cumbersome
and i believe personally
sp 430 is not wholesome and reasonable
and it goes against the state
constitution
and will vote against his bill and ask
we
should not be
adding a burden
to the city a tax burden to the sydney
citizens of new hampshire where we do
not know of the real physical
chair recognizes representative mark
pearson
thank you mr speaker
sb 430 was a wish list from the
department of health and human services
the amendment we just passed
took out
numbers of things from this wish list
it took out items that needed to be
readdressed by a different committee
than ours
committee more subject matter expert
than we
we think that by doing this some
controversial matters will now be given
the full hearing they deserve and oh by
the way
also a discussion
of a good bit of the money that was just
referenced by the previous speaker
the amendment also took out some items
we didn't think were necessary or that
we thought could be more fully thought
through and resubmitted at a later date
what's left includes in part
some tidying up items for example
the authorization to remove the names of
facilities no longer in use from law
the changing of staff titles and
definitions to be more appropriate and
other exciting things like it
by the way these comprise many of the
sections
but we did leave in a few matters we
spent a long time we got out at 8 25 pm
we did a lot of work on this
the bill makes it possible for more home
placements for children in familiar
settings
which will be wonderful for the kids and
cost-effective
for the taxpayers
the bill streamlines background checks
for possible employees at alternative
treatment centers
an important thing to do because of the
labor shortage
the bill reduces the steps involved in
blood testing for lead and therefore
reduces
the cost
the bill sets up a pilot program for the
developmentally disabled adults ages 18
to 21.
i do some work with this community and
have for the last several years so i've
learned that there's a gap of care after
school oversight ends and age 21 care
starts
and because of this
often
and i know the names of many in my area
often parents have to drop out of the
workforce
dhhs wants to set up
not an extensive and expensive program
but a pilot program to see if the ideas
they have for how to
close this three-year gap
make sense and work
cost-effectively
well you get the idea
we've slimmed things down we've kept
compassion and cost effectiveness in
not surprisingly
this bill passed the committee
to one and that one vote was not really
in objection to the important work that
will be accomplished here
it was to underscore and i appreciate
the member doing this it will underscore
that in the future
don't send us bills like this
let the
major issues stand alone so they can
have
even greater consideration than us
having to stay to 8 25 in the evening
thank you mr speaker remember yield to
questions
somebody had requested a roll call i'm
not sure her representative silver
requested a roll call as that's
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the house will be in
order the motion before us has ought to
pass as amended on senate bill 430.
chair recognizes
senator fulson for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that this committee worked
hard and
very long
on this bill
and the amendment that goes along with
it
and that
if i know that many staff people stuck
around to help us make sure it got done
properly and in order and that the only
staff person in the building that was
happy we went till 8 30 was the
custodian because he got time and a half
if i want to
say well done to the health and human
services committee for sticking it out
and getting this done
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on senate bill 430. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your post
you'll press the red button voting
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
233 voting yay 90 voting a committee
and it is referred to the committee on
finance
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs to which was
referred senate bill 444 fn
the house will be in order
an act relative to childhood adverse
experiences treatment and prevention
have been considered the same report the
same the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass senator joe shapiro for
the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and this bill is
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly faster which
was referred senate bill 459 fn yeah
relative
if you're going to have a conversation
an act relative to health care facility
workplace violence prevention program
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass senator lucy weber
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate an erica lay on
for the minority of the committee
bills on second reading open to further
amendment representative leon office
floor amendment 1678-h
and she is recognized to speak to her
amendment
thank you mr speaker i present to you
amendment 1678 which removes a change in
criminal statutes from the bill and
leaves the rest unchanged
senate bill 459 creates a commission on
workplace safety for health care workers
and hospitals and urgent cares in new
hampshire
this is vital to our nurses and other
health care workers
just like everybody in the state country
and world health care workers deserve a
workplace free of violence but unlike
other professions healthcare workers
continue to provide care to people who
are sometimes violent
that is a very unique situation and one
that requires careful consideration
how do we deal with a disruptive patient
who shouts and shoves and does that
despite attempts to de-escalate
if anyone entering the area is exposed
to this a responding police officer will
see it and be able to arrest the person
if that's
that's appropriate
if a visitor gets violent or mouthy they
can be trespassed which means they have
to leave the property and they can't
come back so that solves the problem if
it's not a patient
so neither of those scenarios justifies
an expansion of warrantless arrest
powers
so for those patients who need care and
who fight back in some way it gets
trickier
i feel for those healthcare workers
treating volatile patients that know how
to act the perfect angel when an officer
is around
but that doesn't mean we need to expose
everybody else to warrantless arrest
just because they're in a health care
facility
this needs careful consideration of
people with the right background and
knowledge to figure out if and how we
would change our criminal statutes to
reflect that tricky situation when a
patient needs care
but they're also violating the rights of
somebody else
i don't have the answers i'm on health
and human services
it's going to finance next
they're not criminal justice either
this is something that needs to come
back next year so that it can go through
criminal justice in our body and
judiciary in the other body we can't
make changes with this lightly we put at
risk all of our citizens and especially
those that are already more vulnerable
this is an amendment to fix the problem
and remove the following words in the
criminal code
this would allow warrantless arrest and
i quote
while in the care of a medical
professional on the premises of a
residential care or health care facility
as defined in rsa 152-2 51-2 through
actual or threatened violence interfere
in the provision of medically necessary
health care services
so there's two parts of that that are a
little confusing
the statute itself expands the
definition of workplace violence to
include harsh words
and when you're looking at de-escalation
and some of the other problems
it it makes sense to look at the whole
spectrum but if the statute for
warrantless arrests includes this
definition where harsh words are
violence
that's going to cause a lot of problems
and then medically necessary health care
where is that defined not in our
statutes
compassion for our healthcare heroes is
commendable and i agree that they
deserve
protection but i know that all people
deserve protection under law equal
protection under law is guaranteed in
the 14th amendment the constitution
our rights should not change when we set
foot in a health care facility
without this amendment
they will
this equal protection protects all of us
i can't sit by and let the potential for
a gross violation of human rights
go through without review of criminal
justice and judiciary
i ask you to defer this debate to the
appropriate committees by passing this
amendment
which has support on both sides of the
aisle
and then move this this important bill
onto finance so that we can figure out
how to protect our healthcare heroes
without creating a new constitution
light
area
thank you
does the member yield the questions
yes
senator brownie main choir
thank you mr speaker thank you my friend
from derry
it sounds like the warren or less clause
of
of this bill
applies to all health care facilities
however the database portion of the bill
only applies to hospitals and urgent
care centers
so i assume nursing homes would fall
under the warrantless arrest portion of
the bill
my question is why are nursing homes not
part of the database portion and did the
new hampshire health care association
which repo represents the nursing homes
in the state testify either way on this
thank you very much for the question
this came out of a work group of
hospitals and ambulatory care centers
this does apply to all health care
facilities
but
those two groups asked for this and it
was asked for for hospitals and urgent
cares those are pretty much the front
lines of our health care system
but these warrantless arrests
were these warrantless arrest powers
would go to all health care facilities
everybody is getting lumped into the
same bucket without appropriate
consideration
we did not hear anything from we did not
hear anything from that association
regarding the warrantless arrests and i
don't believe that they testified in
general on the bill as
other than the warrantless arrest
recognize representative weber's
speak against the
floor amendment
thank you mr speaker
we are talking about a very very small
uh expansion of the warrantless arrest
statute
it only refers to misdemeanors because
you can already arrest without a warrant
in the
case of felonies
so
with respect to misdemeanors
law of enforcement already has the right
to arrest
without a warrant
for
misdemeanors that they see happening
so here's the scenario
this expands
that power simply
to
misdemeanors
in health care centers
that interfere with the delivery of
health care that they haven't seen so
there is
an outbreak
the law enforcement didn't see it law
enforcement arrives
currently they have to wait till there's
another
go around
before they do anything about it
and here's the problem
health care workers
are virtually the only victims
of assaultative behavior
who are ethically required to continue
to treat
the person who assaulted them
under no circumstances is anybody going
to halt the treatment
but what this allows
to happen
is there can be an arrest law
enforcement can be there can make sure
that the people who are trying to
deliver care and continue to deliver
care
can do so
uninterrupted
and unassaulted
and remember when they are doing this
they are delivering care not only to the
person who was
committing the assault
but mostly in these settings there are a
lot of other people all around them who
also need critical care
so
we need to have the ability
to be able to allow our health care
workers
to care for all of their patients
in a safe way
that keeps not only the health care
workers but all the other patients safe
as well
so i urge you to accept this small
extension to the statute by pressing the
green button of the
no the red button because it's an
amendment so oppose the amendment by
assembly on has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote members
oh
the motion before us is the
leon floor amendment 1678h
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative edwards for a
uh thank you mr speaker
if
if i know
that
size doesn't matter
and if i know
that a small violation of critical
policy discipline
is as bad as a big violation
and if i knew
that it is not the jurisdiction of
health and human services to
be juggling is i'll use that word
juggling within the criminal statute on
warrantless arrests
would i
then press the green button
so that the amendment will delete the
warrantless arrest portion of this bill
and allow division iii to deal with the
other issues next week thank you
chair recognized representative weber
thank you mr speaker
if i am concerned with the
constitutional rights of every person in
this state
including the right of our health care
workers to do their jobs in safety
and the right of patients and health
care institutions to receive treatment
in safety
would i now press the red button to
oppose this amendment
so we can provide more
protection
to those people who give us care thank
you
the question before us is the
lay on floor amendment one six seven
eight h
this is a
roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your post will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
under an 82 voting yeah 146 voting a
what reasons remember rise to make a
motion mr speaker
state your motion mr speaker i'd like to
a division has been requested members
yes
you can withdraw it
you with wear it
you with wish to withdraw it yes the
the question is now
back on autopass as amended
i
okay
who representative silvia requests a
it is sufficiently seconded
the motion the motion before us
is on autopass as amended this is going
joe recognizes
representative leon for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that we have removed the very dangerous
part about this bill and if i know that
now we can now as it moves to finance
with its financial implications we can
look at the correct look at the correct
implementation and if i know that
different groups within
different groups were against this bill
unamended then would i then press the
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on house bill on senate bill 459
the roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
okay
all members president an opportunity to
264 voting a 64 voting a committee
and 459 is
committee on public works to which was
referred senate bills 278 fn
house will be in order
an act relative to funding for the
piscataqua river turning basin project
and the port authority project
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass so daniel eaton for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
presupposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
oh
committee on public works and highways
which was referred senate bill 346 fna
act requiring the department of
environmental services to conduct
feasibility and impact studies
construction of a pier on hampton beach
have been considered the same report the
same with the recommendations the bill
ought to pass to the michael edgar for
the bills on second reading opened a
further amendment representative power
offers floor amendment 1445
h printed in house record 15 page 34.
recognize the power to speak to her
amendment
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i offer floor amendment 1445
h at the request of the prime sponsor of
senate bill 346
requiring the department of
environmental services to conduct
feasibility and impact studies for the
construction of a pier on hampton beach
this amendment would simply change the
effective day from 60 days after its
passage to take effect upon passage
this simple change would first
allow the hampton beach area commission
to immediately commence its feasibility
in impact studies and second provides 60
additional days for the commission to
both complete
a thorough comprehensive study and meet
the aggressive deadline to report its
findings to the legislature by november
1st 2022
for these common sense reasons i urge my
fellow colleagues to support this floor
amendment by pushing the green button
chair recognizer representative graham
thank you mr speaker my colleagues
the sponsor of this amendment did reach
out to the committee before she filed it
we are in agreement that it does give
some additional time if this bill were
to pass for the the
study to be done and i urge you to adopt
the amendment thank you very much mr
speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass as
oh my mistake i think i've been up here
too long today
this is on the floor amendment one four
four five h
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the floor amendment
is adopted now before us is ought to
pass as amended on senate bill 346. are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
and
majority of the committee on the special
committee on redistricting to which was
referred senate bill 240
an act portioning state senate districts
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that bill
ought to pass senator carol mcguire for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator lucy
weber from the minority of the committee
if you look at the map
that comes with the words
that explain which towns are going to be
in each senatorial district
you will understand that this is the
very picture of gerrymandering
there are a lot of problems here
first of all
the bill splits counties unnecessarily
my own county goes into four different
senatorial districts
where
and my current senator who normally who
currently
serves only cheshire county towns
will now have two hillsborough county
towns imported into his district
while other county towns have been
exported
the towns are geographically sprawling
mr speaker
it's very noisy the house will be in
order the member has a right to speak
if you need to have a conversation take
it out into the annie room
thank you mr speaker
the districts are geographically
sprawling and confusing
one district district nine
stretches from
well two districts stretch
from the connecticut river all the way
to the middle of the state
one district nine is one town wide
70 miles long and it stretches from
hinsdale to bedford
covering a multitude of communities that
the bill as presented
is deliberately gerrymandered for
partisan advantage creating a number of
districts
which are weighted towards the
republicans
and a far smaller number of districts
that are weighted towards the democrats
but the districts that are weighted
towards the democrats are much more
partisan leaning
than the republican districts
because they have been packed with every
available democrat in the state
to the advantage
of the majority party
if you look at our voters
they are relatively evenly split
between democrats and republicans
but the largest voting bloc
is independence
roughly 40 percent for roughly 30
percent of the others
and those independents
really have their voices taken away
by this effort to pack
partisan districts
which are not competitive
and where we don't have to listen to the
majority of our voters
the special committee on redistricting
listen to voters in every county in this
state
and in every county in this state
republicans and democrats told us they
wanted local representation
and they wanted communities of interest
this map doesn't do it
thank you mr speaker
the
you'll notice the previous speaker did
not say that this map was
unconstitutional
in fact it committee they agreed it is
constitutional and legal it meets all
all necessary requirements their concern
is that it's not as good as it could be
well
right
i could have done a better map at least
by my standards the trouble is there are
hundreds of different legal and
constitutional maps for the senate that
would
be legal
there are dozens of criteria to help you
choose between one map and the other
this map has the approval of the
majority of the other body
they have voted for it they recommend it
the house has confirmed that it is in
fact legal and constitutional
and we have no real reason to rewrite
the map that the majority of the other
body has chosen for themselves they
didn't rewrite the map
of house districts that we sent them
and so in
with respect we should just leave this
what reason to memorize motion state
your motion uh i would move that senate
bill 240 be placed upon the table
it is a
proper motion
the motion is to lay senate bill 240 on
the table
roll call has been requested by
senator barbara griffin is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
house will be in order members take your
seats
motion before us is the table senate
bill 240.
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative tim
smith for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that a significant
amount of extra work is needed to craft
a bill
a district bill for the senate district
that is less likely to face immediate
legal challenges
and seriously delay the ability of
senate candidates to file
in just a couple of weeks would i now
chair recognizes barbara griffin for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
legal challenges are no reason to be
tabling a bill and if i know that the
appropriate work and legal
considerations have gone into a bill
which
we are required to address every 10
years in some form another would i vote
against the tabling motion so we can do
what we have been brought here to do
thank you
the motion before us is the table senate
bill 240. it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you press the green
button of your post you press the red
button warning stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president had an opportunity
143 voting a 170 voting a tabling motion
fails
we've already had the debate so we're
going to go right to the vote
i think i heard roll call
i'm sorry representative weber requests
the roll calls that's officially
seconded it is officially seconded this
the motion before us members will be in
their seats the motion before us is a
majority report of what a pass on senate
bill 240. it's a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative weber
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill
disadvantages our cities by splitting
them up and connecting them to towns
that they don't have anything in
connection with some of them quite far
away
and if i know that this bill
disadvantages our towns
by connecting them with larger entities
far across the state with which they do
not share any interests
and if i wonder since when do the
members of this august body settle for
just the bare minimum
rather than doing their very best to
create a bill for the best of all of our
people
would i now press the red button
chair recognize the representative win
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that under the
agreement reached between the two bodies
of the legislature reapportionment
reapportionment of the senate and the
executive council was assigned in the
first instance of the senate and
reapportionment of the house county
commissioners and the congressional
districts was assigned in the first
instance to the house and if i know that
this body has a long tradition of
affording deference to the other body of
the legislature when it comes to
redistricting decisions assigned to that
body in the first instance
and if i know that the other body's work
as reflected in this bill
reapportions the state senate districts
so that all districts are contiguous and
so that all constitutional requirements
are met
and if i also know that no alternative
proposal for
districting the senate districts was
submitted then would i press the green
button to approve this bill
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report about a pass in senate bill 240
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're posting press the
red button voting stations are open for
president
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
172 voting yeah 149 voting a committed
majority committee on special committee
on redistricting to which was referred
senate bill 241
act of portioning executive council
districts having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
bill ought to pass senate lender turquod
for the majority of the committee
bills open the bills on second arena
president bergeron offers minority
amendment 1543h
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron
thank you mr speaker
first i'd like to start off by saying
that if there was a gentleman's
agreement between the two chambers that
we would not amend certain redistricting
bills that they were going to take
control of and they would respect our
wishes for those that we would take
control of i would just remind the house
that in fact the state senate uh did
change the house redistricting plan and
then the bill had to go to the committee
of conference
if senate bill
241 is not amended
nine of the ten counties will be split
apart
and three gerrymandered districts would
be created districts one two and five
on the map for senate bill 241 district
five looks like an alligator's head
chomping at the foot of the district 2
stay puft marshmallow man
district 1 is no longer a solid north
country district
under senate bill 241 the town south of
carroll and franconia and west of
waterville valley have been moved out
and district 1 would then extend all
along the eastern border south to dover
and durham
given the larger population areas in the
southeastern portion of the state the
north country could find itself without
a seat on the executive council
the amendment would establish five
executive council districts that are
constructed to keep as many counties
together as possible
seven of the state's ten counties remain
whole within council districts whereas
under senate bill 241
district one for example incorporates
five entire counties coast carroll
grafton belknap and sullivan counties
under the amendment district 2 which
currently slithers across the width of
the state from hinsdale and charleston
in the west to somersworth in dover in
the east will become much more compact
and encompass merrimack and stafford
counties in the northwestern part of
rockingham
district three remains similar to the
existing district though three towns are
moved to balanced population shifts
district four becomes more compact
the only town that would not share a
border with manchester is derry
and finally district five would
encompass the entirety of cheshire
county and the vast majority of
hillsborough county including nashua
the mapathon citizen mapping project
pointed out
that the amendment is quote relatively
competitive with a slight lean towards
republicans so this is not a democratic
map it is just a better map
i would ask that you please press the
yes button the green yes button to
support the proposed amendment to senate
bill 241
and mr speaker i would request a roll
the chair recognizes representative
barry
thank you mr speaker we'll be brief here
um
this the
the special committee on registration
considered this amendment we decided was
not in the best interest of the state we
voted it down
um i'm asking the body to
confirm the work of the committee and
vote this amendment down so this may be
my last time ever speaking about this
subject in public i want to point
something out about the mapathon group
the nonpartisan mapathon group that my
good friend on the other side just
mentioned the nonpartisan group that is
sponsored by 603 forward granite state
progress and people who enter into
lawsuits with the new hampshire
democratic party to sue the state so
that's about as nonpartisan as they get
thank you mr speaker
a request for a roll call
has been made by representative
bergeron is that sufficiently seconded
uh it is officially seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote on the
amendment
the motion before us is the
three h
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
all members president opportunity vote
145 voting a 175 voting a
amendment failed
the motion before us now is ought to
pass
thank you mr speaker
in my remarks on the amendment i talked
about some of the flaws in senate bill
241.
i would just add to that
that some of the other issues with with
this bill are that it splits 17
high school supervisory unions
it gerrymanders democratic leaning towns
into one district thereby making it
unrealistic for a republican to win in
that district
and as i mentioned before it's splitting
up nine of our ten counties
i would ask therefore that you vote in
opposition to the motion of what to pass
thank you
chair i recognize representative
turcotte
thank you mr speaker good afternoon
everyone
senate bill 241 updates the executive
council or districts based on the
population data that was provided to us
in 2020 federal census
the senate proposed districts distribute
new hampshire's population evenly with
an acceptable
deviation to five executive councilor
districts and that deviation is just
slightly above one percent
regarding the current executive
counselor map one of the complaints we
frequently heard
during our public listening sessions
was that district two stretches and
snakes from the vermont border over to
the new hampshire seacoast that district
no longer exists
now contrary to the fear grenades that
have been lobbed onto the house floor
today about gerrymandering and uh
and packing of districts
the senate has previously approved these
districts and there are no
zero legal basis
that warrants what modification by the
committee
as the map meets all federal and state
constitutional requirements
the majority of the special committee on
redistricting therefore asks that you
support
senate bill 241 by pressing the green
promotion before us is ought to pass on
are you
i was waiting for that
i'm not sure who called it but a royal
car representative griffin
called for a roll call that's officially
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is ought to pass on
senate bill 241 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative spedia
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker if i know the redistricting
committee held public listening sessions
in every county with granite staters
providing us clear direction on the
criteria they wanted us to use when
drawing maps for the next decade
if i heard our constituents ask us to
keep districts compact to keep counties
together and to reject partisanship as
the dominant factor in drawing new lines
i see
that the map in front of me
looks like a jigsaw puzzle
splitting 9 out of 10 counties also be
into multiple districts
with the obvious partisan goal of
packing as many democrats into district
two as possible
and if i believe that new ham that the
people of new hampshire deserve fair
logical districts and that this ain't it
would i now press the red button
the chair recognizes representative lin
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that virtually all of what i said
before with regard to this to the senate
redistricting applies here and if i know
that the other the other body's work as
reflected in this bill reapportions
executive council districts so that all
districts are contiguous and so that so
that all constitutional requirements are
met the deviation between districts
being only slightly above one percent
than what i passed
would i press the green button to
the motion before us is
majority committee report of auto pass
on senate bill 241 this is a roll call
vote you're in favor you'll press green
button if you opposed press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president opportunity to
174 voting 840 voting a the committee
committee on transportation to which was
referred senate bill 442 fn act relative
to the suspension of a vehicle
registration
as a result of evading toll collection
systems having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass senator ted
gorski for the committee
thank you
mr speaker i oppose senate bill 442 and
mr speaker
i have friends
that have done this and i'm considering
registering my 2007
chevy silverado
in maine
and i'm going to remain a resident of
new hampshire
i own an
llc i'm going to sell my truck to the
llc
the llc
can register
that vehicle
maine is one
delaware vermont is another minnesota is
another the minnesota is the best one
and there's four others
so mr speaker why i'm saying this
is why
my friends have done it some
and others are looking into it and i see
a lot of people doing this
is then that way they can get away from
because you don't have to register your
vehicle up there
so with that said mr speaker
that is what's going to happen
when this bill passes
and let me further explain why i know
this to be true
i've read i'm almost positive when i've
been studying this it was in a union
the
connecticut police were quoted in that
article
saying that they have
pretty much this bill
that if you don't pay certain taxes
they're gonna pull your registration so
you can't work to pay those taxes
the police in the article said you drive
down any road in connecticut and you
will see one to three
main license plates on every vehicle
so they're trying they're found a
loophole to get around this law
and that's what's going to happen here
mr speaker and if you really look at a
lot of the tractor trailers
if you look at the trailers
virtually every one of them has a main
license plate
and if you look at the trucks they all
so new hampshire is losing a lot of
this so what i'd like to do mr speaker
to finish this up on my opposition of
senate bill
is to tell you what new hampshire
mr speaker
quote
bill and dispute should not be handled
by invoking the heavy-handed power of
the state to deny the right of travel
and potentially cause a vehicle owner to
lose their job collections of unpaid
bills is a civil matter and should be
handled accordingly
mr speaker i owned the tree business for
25 years plus
in when i
did not get paid it was extremely rare a
matter of fact once i went to small
claims because it was a civil matter
and mr speaker i won that case and i got
paid
this is in the uh new hampshire liberty
alliance
this is a heavy-handed action
to deny somebody travel so if you don't
pay your tolls which i
say you need to pay your tolls
you know because that's the right way to
do it
you know i i believe in the toll system
but this is not the right way
and
i apologize i can't remember it was six
or seven years ago
but i went through the tolls in the
morning and it was approximately 1001
in eight hundredths of a second
i got ticketed
for not having an easy pass
which i did have an easy pass
because my easy pass registered at 10.01
900 of a second
it was like a 25 30 40 fine
and
i went to the dmv
you know to the toll lady and i said
look
i got a picture right here on the new
hampshire easy pass
showing that i paid the toll and it was
100 of a second different from your
ticket
and she goes well we're gonna have to
take this under can uh you know advise
me you know look into this but you'll
probably win
well i wasn't gonna pay that
so at some point they would have pulled
my registration mr speaker because i
wasn't going to pay because i had proof
i paid it it was on my debit card and i
had a picture of them showing it being
paid but because their computer was off
they ticketed me
and then they did say
as i said does this happen a lot and she
goes oh it's killing us right now a lot
of people are getting this
i believe they've corrected it because i
don't hear any complaints about it but
mr speaker that's what's going to happen
is people are going to register their
vehicles somewhere else because they
legally can
thank you mr speaker so i hope you
oppose this and press red thank you is
yes or no yes
okay representative splain you may
inquire
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
member for taking my question i don't
see anything
maybe i missed it is there a dollar
figure that they have to exceed in value
before they start interrupting your life
with uh
suspending your registration and
preventing sale of the car
i do not see so one
not paying one easy password could
uh follow up your registration and yes i
will follow up
thank you remember for the question
thank you for the follow-up so if i went
through the toll once and maybe
two dollars
they could
totally screw up a sale of a vehicle or
suspend my registration etc
that's what could happen they could pull
your registration there is no
monetary you know saying that it has to
exceed a particular date or a particular
amount
thank you thank you remember yield to
further questions yes
thank you for for taking my question um
i was very deeply concerned to hear that
you might have lost your license over a
single unpaid easy pass toll
uh but i i seem to recall reading
something in the bill
um that it's a little bit more involved
than that to actually lose your license
about needing like multiple rounds of
going through and being a serial
violator and having to go months and
months and getting notice after notice
unpaid and unresolved um i'm curious
what part of the bill like led you to
the conclusion that you would have lost
your license after only a single
thank you and if i said you lose your
license i apologize it's only you lose
your registration
yeah
all right
they can do it anytime
thank you mr speaker
i stand in support of sb 442
and when preparing for my argument there
were two quotes
that came to my mind as i was preparing
one from the late
great
author and clergyman
norman vincent peale who once said empty
pockets never held anyone back
only empty heads and empty hearts can do
that
the second is from the late and great
life philosopher
yogi berra
where yogi said once a nickel is not
this bill
is all about closing loopholes
that serial toll evaders have been taken
advantage of
it prohibits the transfer
of ownership of a vehicle to a family
member so basically if i am a serial
tolerator i could sell my ownership to
my vehicle for one dollar to a family
member get new plates
and not have to pay the outstanding
tolls
in testimony the department of
transportation stated in the last year
we had 33 000 plates
that have evaded paying tolls
the year before
we had approximately fifty thousand
my colleagues this has lost revenue to
these plates are people who are
willfully trying to evade paying tolls
in using our toll roads
this bill does allow
in order of the vehicle to have a
hearing so they do have jurisprudence if
they want to talk about the various
tolls and go through this
so in closing i ask you to support the
bipartisan committee recommendation of
15 to 0
by pressing the green button
does the memory yield the questions
remember does not yield
the motion before us is
the committee report of to pass on
senate bill 442
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
also be in order
the motion before us is ought to pass on
senate bill 442
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes
representative waltz for a parliamentary
inquiry
this will be a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
hey
all member president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
218 voting 94 voting a committee reports
adopted
and this bill is referred to finance
uh state your motion
thank you mr speaker i would move
that the debate on senate bills 240 and
241 be printed in the permanent journal
oh okay
um
i was trying to be efficient that's all
i'm move that the debate on senate bill
be printed in the permanent journal
thank you so ordered
mr speaker i move that the debate on
senate bill 241
be printed in the permanent journal
without the without objection so ordered
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred senate bill
376 fn
an act relative to creating a board to
review police incidents involving
citizens affected by mental health
issues
been considered the same report the same
with the recommendations the bill ought
to pass senator john burke for the
committee
bills on second reading open to a
further amendment senate
office floor amendment 1614
h it's in your seat pockets chair
thank you mr speaker
i rise the support of the most to adopt
four amendment 1614h
and what it does
is it increases the appropriation by an
additional 100 thousand dollars
so they can be a part-time employee
to help administer the program
this fourth amendment was
drafted in
at the request of the prime sponsor
of the bill
and that
part-time employee would help
implement the cit training program
the motion before us is abbas 4
amendment 1614
h
for what reason member rise promotion mr
speaker stage motion uh move to uh lay
this uh sb 376 on the table
okay
the motion is in order
the motion before us is the late senate
bill 376 on the table
division has been requested members will
is
the table senate bill 376.
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative levitt
what
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
155 voting yeah 156 voting a the motion
a house will be in order
we're back to the ought to the floor
amendment
representative abbas flora amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
i suppose nay
the eyes have it and the abbess floor
amendment is adopted the bill now is
ought to pass as amended on senate bill
senate sylvia requested a roll call is
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
also be in order
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on senate bill 376.
it's a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button you post
you'll press the red button voting
all members president had an opportunity
206 voting 807 voting a
committee report is adopted
the committee on education to which was
referred senate bill 394 fn and act
relative to the definition of a child
with a disability under special
education laws considered the same
report the same
with the following or amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
the amendment is 1538 age printed in
house record 15 pages 35-36
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
question before us now was ought to pass
with amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
that's a close day
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it is sent to the
chair recognizes the member from auburn
representative osborne for the third
reading motion
thank you resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session being
ordered at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered the third reading be read
a third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that may be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it'd be to meet at the call of the
chair
also be in order
questions on a third reading motion are
ready for the question all those in
favor say
aye eyes have it promotion is adopted
also attend to announcements
chair recognizes representative levesque
thank you mr speaker i just wanted to
let everybody know that tomorrow is girl
scout leadership appreciation day so if
you know a girl scout leader please show
your appreciation and if you are thank
you so much for volunteering your time
to support the girl scouts
of
the green white melons and girl scouts
the house the chair recognizes the clerk
for an announcement thank you mr speaker
just a couple of quick announcements one
we do have a couple of unanimous consent
so please stand by two if you haven't
visited your mailbox in the anteroom yet
please do so before you leave to pick up
your complimentary uh coveted tests if
you do not need or do not want the test
please put them in the small round bin
with a sign on it in the mail room
uh please also at the end of the day
please also remove any trash you might
have in your seat or
here recognizes
representative expedia for unanimous
consent
thank you mr speaker
so
i would just like to apologize
for my actions and during the
conversation on sb41
redistricting is something that has a
really important implications for
so many folks and
you know
obviously an issue that i got really
wrapped up wrapped up about really
passionate about so you know i apologize
for
for showing the map i know that using
that as a prop i should have known
better
so
i just wanted to say that i'm sorry for
doing that and i just appreciate all you
thank you mr speaker
i wanted to take a moment of personal
privilege
and apologize to my colleagues
it was brought to my attention that when
i yelled roll call
it had upset and offended a few people
and it was disrespectful to this room
at sysc i was sexually abused
i want to apologize
and i ask that you my colleagues accept
the g.i recognized the representative
good afternoon colleagues thank you for
question before us is shall the member
continue
roll call has been
a roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
also be in order
the motion before us is shall
representative ammon be allowed to
continue with his unanimous consent this
is a roll call vote members will be in
if you're in favor
you will press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
uh
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your poster press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president an opportunity to
258 voting yay 10 voting nay the member
thank you mr speaker and thank you
colleagues for allowing me to continue
i'd like to highlight a resolution that
we passed earlier uh this morning by
voice vote it was unanimous that was
house resolution 23
reaffirming
this body's position on
first in the nation
presidential primary
so that resolution affirmed our support
for it now first the nation brings jobs
it brings advertising dollars
it brings tourism it brings national
prestige
and it helps our voters be engaged
last thursday the rnc full membership
voted unanimously to make no changes to
their 2024 presidential nominating
calendar keeping iowa
new hampshire south carolina and nevada
in contrast
the national democratic committee
has thrown open the door to a challenge
to our first in the nation status
they've given us two months to
to
prove our case as to why new hampshire
should be the first primary state
and they're opening up the idea that it
could be multiple states running at once
now our secretary of state
secretary scanlan has
reaffirmed his support for keeping our
first to the nation status and and by
statute were
required by state law to be first
but the dnc
and its
obsession with identity politics
we've already had one objection it's
the member may continue i would just ask
that he
be cautious as to what he is saying
so let me clarify
this is not this is not an attack on
anyone in this room we've already
affirmed as a body that
first of the nation should be in new
hampshire so this isn't an attack
personally this is an attack about
national level politics not an attack
but a comment on national level politics
that identity politics
is going to be the reason
if we lose first to the nation status so
we need to
respect each other as individuals and
not as members of groups
and reaffirmed that
we support persons we
could
if
everybody continues to leave
we will lose a quorum and then we will
be unable to move forward with what we
need to move forward with all right
may i just conclude
so we just celebrated the 100th
anniversary of first the nation uh in in
2020 even though we're a small
state
and we have a population of 1.3 million
we have affordable markets we have a
seasoned diverse citizenry and a proven
ability to vet candidates for president
we have the largest state legislature in
the nation and we sponsor a thousand
bills a year we have
we have
acumen at deciding on legislation
and you don't have to be wealthy to run
in new hampshire it's a small market
any natural born citizen who dreams of
being president
of the united states can compete for our
nomination
we have reliably winnowed down the field
of potential candidates
and the ones that survive the vetting
process from our new hampshire
constituents are better for the
experience
and so i i
thank the body for reaffirming our
support for first in the nation
for what members are brief
to make a motion mr speaker stage
emotion
to print the remarks of the previous
without objection
we now have to vote on whether to print
the question before the house is to
print the remarks
of the previous speaker in the journal
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the ice the eyes have it remarks will be
printed
chair recognizes representative perez
thank you mr speaker the members
of the at the house
i'm here
to say that i'm really proud
and i'm honored to be an immigrant
who never thought i was going to be a
member of this house
that's how i want to start and second of
all
i want to say thank you
for the members
of the house for each side of the party
not just democrat but republicans who
reach out to me
after i have to take a hard decision
for my caucus to leave the nhdp
we left the executive committee of the
democratic party
the reason that we left the executive
committee of democratic party is because
my caucus doesn't feel welcomed by the
democratic party
our voices try to be shut down
we can do that
i believe our community has been
tokenized by by many and it's time for
us to win the respect
they only come in us
our opinions when they start to vote
they only come and ask for a boat
but they're never counting on voices
when it comes to make decisions
i will i will say thank you because it's
never been easy for me
to open the
scars how hard it was for me to
cross the border
i'm a survivor a sexual assault at the
border
it's not easy for me to comment and
testify
and told every single all you all of you
how hard it's been
it's been 30 plus years since i crossed
the border
those cars
get open every time that i have to
testify and talk to you guys about
the things that as an immigrant we have
to go through just to get here and
protect her life from the world
i will say thank you
[Music]
and lastly i want to say that
michael my commitment to my community
haven't changed
we change in the name our latino caucus
or just a latino caucus
where everyone can be welcome democrats
republicans and independents
we don't want have
it's been so hard for me to take this
decision
but i'm still the chair of the latino
caucus unknown partisan
we don't want to have a partisan we want
to
make everyone feel welcome
and lastly
i will say the congressional delegation
who's been criticizing previous
administration from going to the border
and speak
negaly about immigrants
what happened to you
you tokenized us
previously to talk negative about
previously administration but now you
utilize an immigrant
to win some vote
shame on you
shame on you for using human
just to try to get those
and trust me they're going to try to get
veterans to go for them
i just let you know that i'm
[Music]
i feel very disgrateful to call myself a
democrat because a lot of democrats have
been calling people for other caucuses
to say to know god in public
do not talk about it
shame on you
for disrespecting my community shame on
you but try to silence our voices
representative osborne moves the house
stand and recess is picking the bills mr
speaker i would like to i'm in the
middle of something
for the purpose of introduction of bills
enrolled bills amendments and enroll
bill's reports receiving messages are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those proposed nay
your eyes have it the motion is adopted
the house is in recess to the call of